[Musique]
alain juillet bonsoir bonsoir vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle signature view nous sommes en
direct c'est une émission un peu
particulière ce soir parce que elle nous
tient à coeur et je voudrais la dédier à
deux personnes qui me sont chers c'est
marc ulmann sélectivement et repère
guillaumot howie de tête une troisième
que vous deviez toujours vivant philippe
caduque absolument aussi comment allez
vous vois ça va très bien pu la visiter
des gens qui étaient à la fois des gens
j'apprécie énormément pour les deux qui
ont disparu et pour le troisième qui est
un ami dont je ne peux que me sentir
bien ici
on va faire géopolitique terrorisme
finances on peut être acquis mais
cyberespace on commence par quoi ce que
la russie vous intéresserait ça paye à
13 intéressant excuse pas souhaité sa
formule de tafer skripal oui vous pouvez
nous en dire votre point de vue est ce
que c'est de la propagande de guerre à
la trappe à ce que les russes ont
quelque chose à se reprocher à ce que
vous avez un point de vue est ce que
vous pouvez être notre pointe de diamant
dont l'analyse de la situation
à faire crier palcy voulez moi je pense
qu'il ya
c'est une opération qui rappelle les
opérations de la guerre froide entre les
américains et russes on est en plein
dedans avec tout ce que ça comporte avec
pour l'environnement qui peut y avoir et
je dirais les manipulations de
l'information qu'il ya dans ces cas là
la fin skripal ce qui est frappant cible
est ce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles on n'a pas répondu
les occidentaux ont démarré à falaise
anglais sous la pression anglaise mais
avec là évidemment les américains mais
il ya une pression très forte qui a
démarré contre la russie en accusant
immédiatement la russie d'avoir fait
l'opération contre skripal bon ce qui
est parfaitement possible mais quand on
regarde réellement ce qui s'est passé
l'histoire telle qu'elle est et racontez
là il ya plein de questions à se poser
parce qu'on n'a pas les réponses et
avant et tant qu'on n'a pas les réponses
on peut se demander si on n'est pas en
train de se faire manipuler se faire
manipuler un peu comme la guerre en irak
entre autres
à ce qu'on peut revenir sur la guerre en
irak et bien sûr qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette affaire d'armes de
destruction massive qui avait été un
petit peu rêver dans le mémoire d'un
étudiant de première année
à moi la guerre en irak si vous voulez
j'ai toujours pensé puis c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui puis à une époque j'ai eu
l'occasion en plus d'être beaucoup plus
impliqué dans cette affaire
il est évident que saddam hussein
n'avait pas les fameuses armes
nucléaires dont on a parlé et donc le
motif majeur qui a été utilisée par le
président bush pour faire la deuxième
guerre d'irak était un motif fallacieux
puisqu'il n'y avait pas d'armes
atomiques et qu'en plus ils rackettaient
dans un état déplorable parce que le
blocus avait fonctionné c'est une des
rares fois où un blocus a fonctionné
parce que les pocus les pays en ont fait
sur d'autres pays mais c'est très rare
les faux ça fonctionne vraiment et en
irak ça avait marché entre les zones
d'interdiction aérienne le fait que les
lions ne plus approvisionner un certain
nombre de produits ici l'oeil d'irak les
airs en grosse difficulté même s'il
avait voulu développer du nucléaire il
en avait plus la capacité même
financière s'ils voulaient et en plus
étaient surveillés et mais en réalité la
manipulation a été totale puisque on
sait maintenant et ça a été écrit s'est
passé plus un secret c'est que les
américains ont fait la deuxième guerre
en irak non pas pour démolir saddam
hussein et récupère un truc mais pour
récupérer des champs de pétrole parce
qu'à l'époque il était convaincu que
l'arabie saoudite allait exploser qu'ils
allaient donc perdre toute la capacité
pétrolière de l'arabie et que comme il
en fallait une ils sont dix l'irak sera
le porte avions ça n'a rien à voir avec
le fait que saddam hussein souhaité
traiter son pétrole en euros
alors ça ça a été suggéré que ça t d à
côté du problème il est certain que
saddam hussein qui après la première
guerre d'irak avec les problèmes qui
avaient ne souhaitait plus n'y a pas que
lui ne souhaitait plus payés en dollars
que les opérations se tassant dollars
donc elles ont été faites elles ont été
faites systématique enfin il voulait les
faire en euros et puis bien sûr la
communauté pétrolières n'étaient pas
chaudes du tout parce que si vous
touchez au système du dollar dans les
échanges pétroliers s'est tous les
équilibres de la monnaie de référence au
niveau mondial qui sont touchés donc
c'était inacceptable pour les américains
c'est vrai mais c'était pas ça la
première la première chose c'est qu'ils
voulaient carrément mettre la main
dessus c'était simple et il fallait un
motif et comme de dire ce saddam est un
bon à rien a tellement dans le
monde qui sont chefs d'état et qui
pratiquent les mêmes méthodes c'était
difficile de faire la guerre pour ça
donc on a amené cette motivation sur
dans ses explications sur l'oeil sur la
gare atomique auquel les américains ont
cru parce que même encore maintenant
j'ai entendu aux états unis dit les gens
me dire heureusement qu'on a fait la
guerre en irak il avait là il allait
avoir la bombe atomique et là qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire beau leur dire
mais c'est idiot c'est trop tard
rappelez-nous un petit peu qui vous aide
pour moi je suis un chat cette vie je
vais je suis chez beaucoup de choses
chasse est cul oui c'est que je vois
c'est que le j'ai commencé après mes
études j'ai fait j'étais dans l'armée
dans les
allées chez les parachutistes comme
officier parachutiste dit qu après
justement je suis belge se passer d'aidé
des unités parachutistes j'étais aux
premières cp et au 9ème je suis passé
aux dec donc au service action qui était
le ferry section du steak après j'ai
quitté je suis parti dans le privé
j'ai fait une carrière dans le privé
temps plein deux sociétés françaises et
étrangères du vieux que j'ai grimpé les
échelons s'ils voulaient en france et à
l'étranger
ensuite en 2000
en 2002 j'ai été nommé directeur du
renseignement à la dgse
ce qui était le slogan sia est devenu
qu'était devenue la dgse c'est
l'équivalent du moule à gaufres l'enduro
des légendes
exactement c'est ça et puis et après on
m'a on m'a muté et avec mon accord bien
sûr on m'a muté auprès du premier
ministre pour m'occuper de
l'intelligence économique parce qu'il
fallait absolument développer
l'intelligence économique en france et
on n'arrivait pas à la développer dans
dans les services on n'arrivait pas à
développer dans certains ministères donc
on a eu la l'époque c'était jean pierre
raffarin mais avec le président chirac
jean pierre raffarin et toute son équipe
ont sont dit on va faire on va le faire
auprès de nous et donc j'ai été nommé
comme haut responsable à l'intelligence
économique
je suis resté c'est que j'ai lancé le
j'ai lancé je dirais on peut dire en
france la deuxième vague de
l'intelligence économique ce qu'on avait
eu une première dans les années 90 avec
robert youyous et bernard lambert et
c'est pour ça que je n'oublie pas quand
tout à l'heure vous citiez guillaume
mois pour moi guillaume wack qui j'ai
travaillé ensuite mais même pendant
parce que je me suis avant d'être nommé
à l'intelligence économique je me suis
intéressé depuis très longtemps
d'intelligence économique j'ai fait les
pratiques et je les ai utilisés avant
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai été nommé directeur du
renseignement hostos à l'époque à la
dgse c'était pour implanter
d'intelligence économique à la dgse et
là ça a été un échec c'est un échec
pourquoi parce que le parce que les
fonctionnaires et surtout le dire est
que le directeur général le directeur de
l'époque ne voulait pas entendre parler
de développement économique
il avait un background de spécial non
parce que le directeur en question il
avait fait chausser en plus le directeur
du service avait fait hec mais c'était
un ambassadeur et sa vision c'était une
vision géopolitique purent
alors que moi j'étais là pour justement
à me dire à côté de la vision
géopolitique il faut prendre en compte
l'économique et c'est d'autant plus on
l'a vu après que c'était une vraie
nécessité parce qu'aujourd'hui la guerre
on peut dire qu'on le veuille qu'on le
veuille pas y'a toujours um au moins une
partie économique en télé pas totalement
économique et confient les conflits
puissance entre les pays sont toujours
avec une base économique aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de problème quand vous êtes
passés dans le privé
vous aviez toujours des contacts avec
votre ancienne maison parce que ça se
fait toujours est ce que si vous voulez
aller clock les aurélie non est-ce que
dgse mais toujours des hommes de paille
à la tête d'entreprises françaises à
l'étranger
j'irai pas ça d'abord j rep homme de
paille d'abord première mais c'est pas
ça si vous voulez ce qu'il ya c'est que
avant tout les services de renseignement
ont besoin d'un formateur et surtout à
l'époque encore plus comme un temps
parce que maintenant avec les nouvelles
technologies c'est plus du tout la même
chose mais à l'époque à la force d'un
réseau de renseignement c'était son
réseau d'informateurs et les réseaux
d'informateurs ce sont des gens comme
vous comme moi ce sont des gens qui se
comparent tous dans des zones où il peut
y avoir des choses intéressantes à
connaître ou d où des groupes de gens à
rencontrer avec lesquels il faut
discuter bon il certain que moi j'étais
quand j'ai quitté le service action très
vite après j'ai continué à travailler
avec le jury je le dis dans le plan que
joue le dirai pas si ça n'avait pas été
dit par madame alliot-marie qu'était la
ministre de la défense kim anh homme qui
a conduit à ce qu'il m'a fait nommer
avec jean pierre raffarin et le
président chirac là comme directeur du
renseignement et quand on veut gagner
mais comment vous avez pu mettre
quelqu'un qui vient du privé
d'antony comme directeur du
renseignement la réponse a été claire
elle a dit mais attendez vous le pensez
tout de même pas qu'on nomme quelqu'un
qui n'ait pas dans le système un poste
pareil donc la réponse était là revenons
sur la russie mais quand la russie
prévient l'angleterre de se méfier un
petit peu de tout ce brouhaha médiatique
est ce que vous pensez qu'on se dirige
vers la guerre
la vraie
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas parce
que alors si vous prenez il ya déjà eu
dans le passé entre l'angleterre si je
prends l'angleterre et la russie 1 dans
le passé il ya déjà eu des crises
majeures sur des cas d'espionnage ou de
grey de suite de affaire d'espionnage
entre l'angleterre et la russie il ya
toujours eu des relations très
particulières entre ces deux pays faut
pas oublier tous les espions russes qui
étaient en angleterre à une époque aller
avec philby blunt de mclean hébergeurs
et puis il y avait vassal de grégory
vassal enfin il ya eu toute une série
d'affaires et à chaque fois il ya eu un
grand scandale des hurlements des
anglais des expulsions de diplomates il
ya tout un show c'est un véritable show
ciblées mais sur le fond
je pense que si si il ya eu achats
cockpit shaq fu dans la chaque fois il
ya eu des tensions mais ça s'est arrêté
et là je pense que moi je ne crois pas à
la guerre parce que je pense que mana
mana mais theresa may dans cette
affaire-là on attirait un énorme profit
d'ores et déjà l'un attirant un énorme
profit s'il voulait ce type
en montrant en prenant une position
extrêmement fermes contre les russes et
en réussissant à cordes a regroupé
autour d'elle les pays européens pour
dire il faut manifester tous ensemble
contre la russie ce sont des voyous elle
a réussi à faire passer le message
c'était une femme forte une femme qui ne
se laissaient pas faire et une femme qui
était capable de fédérer les occidentaux
où il chante très mal informés nathan
des ennemis mais non parce que pour elle
c'est là c'est la meilleure réponse
qu'elle pouvait donner aux critiques
internes qu'il y avait dans son pays sur
le break site où tout le monde disait
allez pas bonne elle ne se bat pas elle
connaît un corps donne pas ses ministres
enfin bref hall et les anglais
l'accusait de quantité de choses son
image se dégrader et elle a en revanche
dix ans sur la sphère skripal elle s'est
donné une stature elle sert donner une
stature elle s'est redonné une force de
fait très peur aux dépens des russes et
c'est facile puisque les russes
pouvaient pas répondre
et quand les russes ont dit mais nous on
veut participer à l'horizon des on veut
participer on veut quand on veut on veut
être avec vous et dire il encore demandé
aussi au conseil de sécurité la
bombe ont ça se comprend eux si eux
disent ils défendent une hauteur il dit
nous sommes nous sommes innocents donc
laissez nous avoir accès au dossier les
anglais disent pas question de vous
laisser avoir accès au dossier donc
forcément déjà il ya un problème
alors la question c'est pourquoi les
anglais ne laisse pas les rues saint
lary dit on peut pas les laisser puisque
c'est eux qui ont fait le coup mais
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est beaucoup moins clair que ce qu'on
raconte suivre parce que ça peut être ça
peut être les hommes de boutines mais
pourquoi l'aurait-il fait
skripal il a trahi son pays il a donné
des agents russes aux anglais c'est pas
très bien dans aucun pays du monde ça
passe bon les choses ont évolué à
l'époque à l'époque de des français de
farwell à l'époque de petrov pour
farwell enlever trop chouette hein à
l'époque de 2 des américains
également quand il ya eu des espions
prolé pour les occidentaux en russie les
ont tués ils les ont exécutés d'une
manière ou d'une autre bon ce qui est
pâle on l'a mis en prison et quelques
années plus tard il a servi de monnaie
des changes donc s'il avait voulu qu'il
en avait tellement voulu il aurait tué
avant il aurait exécuté après la fin à
la fin de son procès en disant tu as
trahi tu a reconnu que tu as trahi tu as
donné d'aider des agents russes aux
occidentaux bon bah tu es condamné à
mort est terminée bon ils l'ont pas fait
ils ont mis en prison et ils s'en sont
servis comme monnaie d échange pourquoi
voulez-vous que quelques années plus
tard
cinq ans plus tard ils viennent faire
une opération sur ce type là il ya
quelque chose qui va pas dans cette
affaire-là pourquoi cinq ans après il
irait ses efforts c'est qu'il ya autre
chose est-ce que skripal été mêlé à
d'autres affaires qu'on ne sait pas est
ce que c'est les problèmes financiers
est-ce que c'est des règlements de
comptes entre ligue arc parce que quand
même les russes sont pas des enfants de
choeur non plus aya commun des
oligarques qui ont fait leur fortune à
coups de pistolet quand même et d'hommes
demain donc tout ça c'est très compliqué
et moi je suis certain qu'en fans
d'histoire et il ya de grandes chances
je dis pas toutes les chances n'y a de
grandes chances pour qu'on s'aperçoive
que ce n'est pas poussines qui a fait le
coup que c'est peut-être des russes mais
c'est pas poutine
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire d
opération sous faux drapeau
ça se fait ça se fait mais il faut pas
se faire prendre c'est ça se fait ça se
découvre une bourse et s'annonce comme
un autre ouais entre autres à cause des
passeports suisses oui mais tout le
temps il ya tout ya toujours eu dans
deux le les services de renseignement le
problème s'est passé de se pas se faire
pendre pour pas se faire prendre il faut
voir des opérations qui réussissent bien
sûr mais au cas où il y aurait des
enquêtes qui remonte il faut essayer de
mettre des coups de feu et des coupe feu
et coups feu
c'est ça peut être effectivement
l'identification des gens avec des
passeports ou d origine d'autres pays
alors évidemment les pays concernés un
pas ça c'est clair
moustache il s'est fait buter ou pas
l'ancien président de chez total non non
à la la je crois pas parce que j'ai lu
j'ai beaucoup discuté de ça avec des
gens proches de lui y compris en russie
et c'est tellement incroyable son
histoire et puis ça s'est joué à rien
parce que l'avion aurait aurait commencé
à décoller cinquante mètres plus au plus
tôt le train d'atterrissage passer au
dessus du au dessus du chasse-neige et
il y avait rien c'est moi je crois que
c'est un comble c'est un concours de
circonstances qui est dramatique un jeu
les huits un dramatique pas seulement
parce que ça a tué un grand très grand
chef d'entreprise français mais je pense
que margerie avait pour la relation
franco russe oui pour les relations
franco russes et pour la nation
iranienne aussi parce que margerie avait
une image extraordinaire dans les pays
du tiers monde
tu étais pas parce que c'était un
personnage et qui avait peur de rien et
qui avait le courage de discuter avec
tout le monde et qui avait réussi à
s'imposer sur le marché international et
son successeur quelles que soient ses
qualités je mets pas en doute ses
qualités aura besoin de pas mal de temps
avant d'arriver à avoir la même
envergure et la même capacité
on viendra un peu plus tard sur la
russie qu est ce que l on peut se dire
sur les révolutions arabes
là je demande à philippe de prêter
l'oreille des révolutions arabes c'est
stimuler ses pas stimulé ya des
questions de deux ans je pense que c'est
très clair blanc les reines les
révolutions arabes s'il voulait au
départ
il faut il faut voir les choses il ya
des signes si vous voulez y ait des
signes très forts qui montre bien qu'il
y avait quand même une certaine
coordination
bon si on grave derrière on s'aperçoit
qu'en définitive
nos amis américains se sont rendus
compte surprend l'histoire de l'île pays
arabes on s'est rendus conduit sont
rendus compte que ben ali en tunisie
était de moins en moins appréciée non
pas à cause de lui d'ailleurs mais à
cause de la fin de sa femme et de la
famille de sa femme qui était en train
de piller le pays y avait en le fils est
redevenu avait pardon le président le
président égyptien qui voulait faire
passer son fils comme président après
lui et les militaires n'en voulait pas
parce que les militaires considéré que
en egypte c'est un militaire qui doit
avoir le pouvoir et c'est pas un prince
régnant s'il voulait ve succédant à son
père donc il y avait une opposition de
ce côté là et il s'était rendu compte
qu'il y avait aussi des problèmes en
turquie c'est pour ça qu'on a retrouvé
là le fils d'un diplomate que le parfait
kit du petit révolutionnaire en egypte
entre autres entre autres probablement
oui mais si vous voulez c'est sûr que
les américains ont joué à un moment les
frères musulmans les américains étaient
convaincus souvenez vous ce que je vous
disais sur la guerre d'irak quand les
américains ont vu qui se passe en arabie
saoudite ils ont dit qu'ils les avaient
remises à 8 va exploser et
les islamistes vont prendre le pouvoir
par tous car c'était la grande peur de
l'époque les islamistes vont prendre le
pouvoir par tous donc la question ça a
été
qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver qu'il fasse
barrage à l'islamisme et ce qu'ils ont
trouvé c'est les frères musulmans c'est
une erreur du jugement est indiscutable
mais
e.on sont dit si on met des frères
musulmans ce seront des islamistes mais
qui ne seront pas trop donc ça va
permettre de calmer le jeu et de
contrôler la situation et ils ont
favorisé et derrière les occidentaux
puisque quand on parle l'amérique
toujours une ensemble de pays qui
suivent ils ont favorisé l'arrivée des
frères musulmans en egypte en tunisie et
en turquie
où des amis en turquie c'était un ami
des frères musulmans le qu'est ce qui
s'est passé eh bien ça a échoué partout
sauf en turquie mais ça a échoué en
salle jouée à
en egypte parce que les la population à
rejeter les frères musulmans il faut pas
l'oublier il ya eu un référendum et que
ça en demandant tout le monde nous dit à
mort s'il a été chassée bon la
répression a été très dur mais ce que
les gens oublient d' c'est que quand 6 6
a pris le pouvoir un peu à peu à faire
un coup d'état fait à la suite et s'est
fait élire mais c'est à la suite d'un
référendum qui a été fait dans le pays
où vous avez un plus de la moitié de la
population qui a voté en disant on ne
veut plus des frères musulmans c'est
quand même énorme si on est un cas
unique il ya eu un rejet absolu et en et
en tunisie c'était un peu différent
parce que les frères musulmans avaient
pris le pouvoir mais là c'est un coup de
chance pour moi je conserve un coup de
chance extraordinaire ce sont les femmes
tunisiennes merci bourguiba qui leur
avait donné la liberté dans les femmes
tunisiennes qui ont dit on n'est pas
d'accord et qui ont réussi à renverser
le sis a empêché de le système se met en
place donc donc vous réfutez le deuxième
prisme de lecture qui est les américains
ont enflammé la ceinture méditerranéenne
pour empêcher l'europe de se projeter
dans ses anciennes colonies
chez ses anciens bras je pense pas si
vous voulez je pense je pense que c'est
alors que c'est un prisme qui était
envisagé mais on a entendu j'ai entendu
cette version comme bien sûr on a
entendu la version allait elle avait
elle l avait des raisons je ne dis pas
qu'elle est erronée avait raison mais
après avoir regardé tout ce qui s'est
passé avait entendu ou comment vous
l'avez entendu ou ce prix sema d'andean
des think tanks de gens un peu de qui
regarde un peu plus proche un peu plus
profondément que la moyenne ce qui se
passait dans le point et type de sim
tant que vous avez des nous pardon des
nous donc j'ai pu en mémoire pour sa
fête ça fait déjà quelques années cette
affaire l'insulté je n'ai pas en mémoire
comme ça si ça revient je pourrais vous
le dire mais j'ai pas mais ce que je me
souviens très bien ces discussions que
j'ai pu manger plus à voir où j'ai pu
entendre ou certains disaient
effectivement ça c'est pour nous
empêcher mais je mets mais je ne crois
pas moi je pars ce moment je pense pas
du tout parce que je connais bien
l'egypte ottomane pardon cool
l'outaouais
et je connais et puis je connais bien
aussi la tunisie si vous voulez donc
c'est ces deux pays moi je connais bien
le moyen le moins - bien que mon ami
chou et que vous avez reçue mais je
connais bien bien c'est très cette
région j'ai beaucoup d'amis en egypte
j'ai beaucoup d'amis je dise amis en
tunisie j'en avais un peu dans toute la
région et j'en ai toujours
le c'est clair que le en ce qui concerne
la il ya eu quand même une volonté une
peur américaine de voir tout ce tout le
moyen-orient leur échapper complètement
et la volonté de changer en mettant des
frères musulmans parce que c'est ce que
les accords méditerranéen s'ils n'y a ni
si les souvenirs sont bons est ce que
c'était les prémices d'une garde
prétorienne européenne contre les flux
migratoires
non je pense pas je pense que les flux
migratoires si vous voulez c'est le
résultat de nos erreurs moi je pense que
c'est surtout ça les flux migratoires si
vous voulez
y a pas le
si on reprend un peu ainsi les flux
migratoires vous êtes vous là on a
brutalement découvert il ya quelques
années on a vu arriver des fous
tout le monde vous les médias dans la
presse partout on a vu arriver des
masses de gens depuis le moyen orient et
le proche orient on a vu arriver des
masses de gens depuis l'afrique
et y en a pas voulu regarder ce qui se
passait derrière savoir que pour
l'afrique en réalité ce qu'on voit
arriver c'est 10% des migrants parce que
il ya déjà des transferts entre pays
pauvres et pays riches en afrique
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on
voit chez nous comme on a pu le voir
entre le burkina faso et la côte
d'ivoire par exemple ou le mali et la
côte d'ivoire où le mali le sénégal pour
prendre des exemples on a eu donc il ya
eu un des grands mouvements de
population il y en a eu aussi vers le
nord ce qui a c'est klaus a changé c'est
qu'avant c'étaient des structures assez
in organisé et à partir du moment nous
avons créé des zones de non droit c'est
la libye on assiste à sarkozy c'est un
oui merci bhl
comment merci sarkozy merci bien chaînes
à bas je pense que celui qui a une la
plus lourde responsabilité au départ
c'est quand même bhl
assez clair
y'a pas photo puisque c'est quand même
lui qui a amené les katiba de benghazi à
l'elysée dont on savait que c'était des
katiba dont est un certain nombre de
membres pour ne pas dire la totalité des
djihadistes comme on peut laisser faire
ça
c'est la cécité vous savez c'est des
choses qui arrivent a eu l'idée on peut
d'abord d'abord on est pas toujours que
des gens bien dans la banlieue et dans
les relations internationales vous
n'êtes pas toujours allier qu'avec des
petits dés des personnes des personnes
et des groupes qui sont formidables vous
pouvez aussi fréquenté des voyous il ya
des fois où c'est nécessaire à ces
chiens de guerre des guerres par proxy
par exemple oui
vous avez vous pouvez avoir des cas où
on peut se sont peu on peut aider alors
soit pour aider un pays qui est un pays
ami et qui vous dit donne moi un coup de
main ça arrive sur des exemples
à écouter ya quand même moi je pense
qu'il restera et on a on a un exemple en
europe qui est quand même un jour les
écrits les dires et les historiens vont
travailler là dessus c'est l'histoire
des balkans quand même la serbie ouais
parce qu'il faut quand même regarder
voilà on avait la veille zones qui
étaient effectivement avec des problèmes
certes avec la mort de tito et qu'ils
avaient besoin d'évoluer bon les
allemands ont provoqué tout de suite
l'indépendance de la croatie du morceau
crois tu pas ce que ça c'était des vieux
lien entre l'allemagne et la croatie
avec les oustachis donc c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui bon et le reste c'est
devenu un champ clos et dans ce champ
clos on voit bien que on nous ont
encouragés à faire la guerre en bosnie
en particulier
ben là c'est clair c'était l'otan qui
était derrière souvenez-vous des
jugements et autres vous aviez on a tout
le monde a été alors nous a dit il faut
faire la guerre dans cette zone là
contre 1000 sévisse contre la contrôler
les serbes 1 et quand on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui on a on a aidé des
gens dont il est avéré que ce sont des
gens qui ont eu des comportements pour
le moins illégaux je suis gentil en
disant ça parce qu'il ya eu des erreurs
et surtout c'est devenu le chancre de
l'europe parce qu'actuellement la bosnie
avec l'albanie sont les deux pays d'où
viennent la plupart des problèmes un de
sécurité en europe 1 les boyaux la
drogue et les armes tout et en plus ce
sont des gens extrêmement violent et
brutaux on le voit ils ont aujourd'hui
le milieu du bassin rhodanien français
est contrôlée en grande partie par les
gens venus de la barre donc c'est pas
une réussite si les on a on a fait une
guerre en définitive pour mettre des
voyous à la tête d'un certain nombre de
zones pour changer bah ouais c'est non
pas une réussite on ouvre une petite
parenthèse
vous parliez des balkans on va parler
fait que nous oui les charniers de
timisoara oui le heat l'a fait et puis
on va parler aussi fait que nous
avec la so cool propagande russe on
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la nouvelle
loi sur l'affectueuse
alors moi d'abord sur l'effectif d'abord
je vous dirais que je vois qu'elles ont
toujours existé donc ça c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui qui a eu des fausses
nouvelles qui ont été propagées avec les
moyens et les médias deux du moment
page et par qui
ben salem a des gens qui ont intérêt à
les propager ça peut être des idées dans
tous les coins de l'histoire du monde si
vous voulez un bon il ya toujours eu des
a toujours eu des fausses nouvelles qui
ont été lancées par les impôts d'une
manipulation qui ont été faites dans des
zones par les autres
la russie s'est distingué après après la
révolution russe après 1917 dans la
mesure où c'est un certain nombre de
gens chez eux ont vraiment travaillé sur
la désinformation la disette des
informaticiens comme ils disent
ils ont travaillé là dessus et ils ont
expliqué à l'époque
ils ont expliqué qu'on pouvait donc
effectivement pas avec des fausses
nouvelles et en manipulant l'information
vous pouvez manipuler les foules s'ils
voulaient ils ont mis en place des vrais
technique bon la propagande si tu peux
lire ces mots propagande qui a été
utilisé aussi par d'autres bons
indiscutablement
avec le développement des médias
aujourd'hui tous les coups de les formes
de médias vous pouvez véhicule est
extrêmement vite de fausses informations
tout le truc le truc c'est d'arriver à
véhiculer l'information qu'ils sont
suffisamment crédible pour qu on les
vérifie pas où
on ne puisse pas aller vérifier et de
cannes figure celui on les vérifie pas
où on le beau bien on a pas là où alors
on nous on ne sait pas comment faire et
c'est tout les coudes les problèmes
actuels l'effectif y en a dans tous les
sens si vous voulez parce que on peut
vous raconter des conneries quand on
disait tout à l'heure saddam hussein à
la bombe atomique c'était une fête news
c'était absolument impossible bon quand
quand on vous dit
[Musique]
et
pour l'effectif j'ai eu vraiment
préciser aussi que il ya plusieurs
sortes de fait qu'il y ait aussi à une
secte ou ce n'est pas forcément
totalement fausse bien au contraire la
meilleure des flics news c'est celle qui
a une part de vérité et une part de fo
l'un est un exemple
alors on parle beaucoup de la birmanie
actuellement à cause d'un ring 1
derwinger exactement on pas d'héroïne
galandon jusque là
bon effectivement on est écouté et puis
on dit un véritable génocide et running
à ce que les mais par contre quand on
vous dit ça on ne raconte pas on ne
regarde pas l'histoire l'histoire que
laquelle c'est que quand on a créé le
bangladesh le pakistan et le bangladesh
par rapport à la birmanie les royens
gars que paie une partie de la birmanie
ont demandé d'être rattachée au
bangladesh et de ne pas faire partie de
la birmanie donc il était sécessionniste
un peu comme les catalans aujourd'hui
eh oui donc ça c'est le première chose
la deuxième c'est que c'est une
population on les présente et c'est
effectivement ils sont chassés dans des
conditions terribles mais on les
présente comme ça mais on ne dit pas non
plus qu'ils sont extrêmement violent et
que par exemple on me raconte pas le
début de l affaire actuelle c'est quoi
c'est un bonze et vous savez que dans la
population eu lieu à dia tic un bon
c'est donc c'est un prêtre local
qui vivent de la charité puisqu'il n'a
rien il n'a aucune ressource il vit de
la charité tout le monde et donc on lui
doit et d assistance et la tradition
bouddhiste partout bon et bien le
premier incident qui a eu en pays
rowling a c'est un bon ce qui est venu
dans la village running à et qui a été
lynché par la population musulmane
ça a mis hors d'eux les population
birmane
bouddhiste qui sont intervenus c'est
comme ça que ça a commencé vous voyez
donc pour vous dire et là il ya eu un
engrenage je suis pas en train de vous
expliquer quarante ans que ça dure quand
même oui mais oui c'est pas pour des
questions de pétrole à bahia bakari a eu
plein d'autres choses ciblé le père soit
sur le pétrole birman avec total quand
on a accusé total ça c'était une eq news
on avait accusé total de faire
travailler dans les forages pétroliers
en birmanie un des prisonniers des
prisonniers politiques et autres de la
junte birmane c'était absolument faux
mais est ce à l'équipe qui avait inventé
ça c'est fait que news il s'était
inspiré du camp de la rivière kwaï et
pour ceux qui connaissent le film
c'était sa c5 si j'avais inspiré voulait
s'y fier c'est ça ouais c'est ça c'est
incroyable il avait vu ce film ils ont
dit mais tiens on pourrait faire ça on
va là on va sortir un truc contre total
le pont de la rivière kwaï mais le
problème c'est que total à l'époque a
fait une erreur colossale c'est qu'ils
n'y ont pas cru ils ont pas pris ça au
sérieux cela dit on peut pas nous
accuser de faire travailler les
prisonniers c'est pas possible donc il
n'y aurait pas cru et c'est la grande
erreur parce que une fake news plus elle
dure et plus elle devient crédible c'est
un peu comme la parole politique non un
peu
est ce que les journalistes à vos yeux
une part de responsabilité est ce que
les journalistes sont toujours pour
certains
qu'une chemise avec certains services de
renseignement soit français sous
l'étranger
moi je suis plus à raison je suis moins
dur que vous sur certains vols a pris
sur la plupart des journalistes
le problème du journaliste aujourd'hui
c'est que on n'a plus le temps de faire
des investigations supplémentaires vers
londres partait pour passer six mois
quand churchill à les couvrir la guerre
en afrique du sud il partait pour des
mois et des mois ça coûtait une fortune
au journal qui finançait sa bon c'était
possible à l'époque parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup d'art d'une part il y avait de
l'argent les journaux rapporter beaucoup
d'argent et d'autre part parce que c'est
elle que le concept même et puis y avait
pas les médias quand comme on a
aujourd'hui la circulation de
l'information qu'on a aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai comment ça se
passe dans la plupart des cas ces sont
les agences de presse qui font
l'information c'est pas les journalistes
le journaliste y rajoute des ligues idée
l'oeil il rajoute des informations
complémentaires par rapport à un message
de base qui a été envoyé par une agence
de plus une agence de presse alors le
journaliste lui il va faire des trucs
souvent formidable il va sortir il va
aller chercher alors qu'angers
formidable il va aller chercher des
enfants mention là où nous allons
prouver donc il va il a pas le temps
d'aller voir des gens donc il va aller
en général qui va faire s'est il va
prendre yahoo google ou ce que vous
voudrez bon ou bien où les roulés ou les
où les chinois bon qu'est ce qui va se
passer il va avoir une vision de
l'information qui est celle de la banque
de données il va s'en servir il va faire
les vagues il va mettre une trempe une
explication et à la fin de la journée
vous apercevez que chaque journal chaque
média radio télévision tout le monde a
rajouté des couches chacun en mettant un
petit peu plus le fond du problème c'est
qu'à la fin de la journée si vous dites
est ce que l'information de la vence de
presse est vrai
la fin vous apercevez que personne ne
l'a vérifié et c'est ça le fond du
problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a on a
à peu près 20% de toutes les
informations qui circulent qui sont
fausses et c'est pas la faute du
journaliste alors après vous avez un
deuxième volet c'est ce que vous disiez
sait les relations des journalistes les
journalistes ils ont les uns et les
autres des réseaux quand même les l'ubs
l'horizon des réseaux alors ce sont des
réseaux idéologique on en connaît un
bout ce sont des réseaux de gens qui ont
et qu'ils ont connue dans le cadre de
leur carrière un peu partout et c'est
évidemment le journaliste qui a ses
réseaux qu'est-ce qui fait il va
contacter ses contacts ses
correspondants et il va avoir des
informations
si ces informations sont justes c'est
parfait si les informations sont
tendancieuses biaisé ou autre il est
piégé et ça ça devient de la
manipulation
comment comment on peut laisser
comment sont venues cette question
comment on peut laisser les journalistes
sans formation contre l'intoxication par
des puissances étrangères à ce qu'il
faudra des formes et avec des techniques
issues du renseignement oui moi je crois
je crois qu'on devrait commencer par les
écoles de journalisme
on devrait apprendre aux gens à se
méfier d'un certain nombre de choses
c'est à dire qu' il faudrait apprendre
aux gens à ne pas croire instantanément
tout ce qu'on leur dit c'est pas pour ça
c'est un étal et cela trop tard est ce
que le prisme de lecture et incurable
optimiste est ce que le prix d'un est-ce
que l'on parlera d'optimisme ce que le
prisme de lecture et l'esprit critique
de la population n'a pas été trop usé
par un journalisme qui va vous loue
c'est sûr que dans l'eure dans un pays
comme la france
il est indiscutable que la pensée unique
ce qu'on appelle la pensée unique fait
des ravages
parce que vous ne pouvez plus dans ce
pays penser différemment des autres
sinon vous êtes mal vu et c'est dans
tous les domaines parce que c'est pas
une question d'être de gauche de droite
212 que vous dame pris dans le
renseignement mais bien sûr parce qu'il
ya chaîne de commandement quand on fait
remonter du renseignement brut soit que
mme agences comme un honorable
contributeurs ou est ce que la chaîne de
commandement est prête à ne pas entendre
ce que le patron ne veut entendre parce
que le politique veut entendre c'est
tout le problème là vous poser un
problème ça a été très bien expliquée
par le patron de la cia après laffaire
de l'irak justement qui a fait un
bouquin qui s'appelait over the storm
dans la tendance dans la tempête dans la
tourmente et sur lequel il expliquait
justement ses propres erreurs en lisant
j'ai eu tort
de laisser le politique n'utiliser
qu'une partie de mes informations pour
donner une vision fausse de la réalité
c'était après l'intervention de powell
vous savez du chef d'un blanc désarmé à
l'onu sachant qu'une traction ou là il
avait montré des trucs invraisemblables
je me souviens il y avait il avait
montré un moment un camion en dix ans ce
camion fait de l'épandage chimiques
d'abord il suffit de réfléchir une
seconde c'était une absurdité parce que
s'ils faisaient de l'épandage chimie
tout le monde était mort au tournant les
cadres dont lé conducteur du camion faut
peut-être réfléchir un petit peu mais le
pire c'est c'est pas ça c'était que le
camion en question à l'évidence c'était
pour gonfler des ballons sondes et ce à
tous les militaires du monde entier
utilisant ce type de camion pour les
balances on le savait
donc si vous voulez mais quand quand une
population quand des gants des auditeurs
ou des lecteurs ou les spectateurs en
définitive sont tellement conditionnés
ils ne se rendent plus compte de ce
qu'on leur montre si vous voulez il ne
voit que ce qu'ils veulent voir c'est le
problème de la pensée unique vous ne
voyez que ce qu'on vous a dit qu'il faut
regarder et vous voyez pas les a côté un
service de renseignement son secret
justement c'est c'est de regarder tout
ce qu'il ya à côté et puis de le faire
remonter mais si au dessus les gens
veulent pas l'écouter ça marche pas et
si les patrons du service de
renseignement pour des raisons de
carrière ou de convictions idéologiques
vous dise non ça on peut pas le montrer
moussa en veux pas où ça vous avez tort
moi ça m'est arrivé d'avoir des gens qui
m'ont dit non je suis pas d'accord avec
vous c'est faux j monsieur c'est qu'on
appelle du ac 1 renseignements
absolument sûr absolument sûr il n'y a
pas la moindre doute
ce n'est pas vrai point barre ben après
votre enseignement il est peut-être le
formidable mais personne ne va les
utiliser puisqu'il est le maire rôle
mais elle était noir tu as compris
philippe
on revient un petit peu sur la ceinture
méditerranéenne ont la syrie oui tout se
passe bien on est encore en train
d'apporter la démocratie pour les
petites filles où on va on va la syrie
la syrie c'est une affaire si vous
voulez la pas être pardon de paille aps
et de poing d'absolument la syrie tout
le monde va mal tout le monde un certain
nombre de gens maintenant connaissent le
départ de l'histoire le départ usant
c'est une question gazière
le choix de bachar entre un pape qui
venait du qatar qui passait par l'arabie
saoudite la jordanie la syrie et qui
allaient vers la turquie où ils devaient
se brancher sur un autre pas y
por le south stream je résume un petit
peu accepté sa mousse très bon et un
autre les iraniens qui se voulait faire
un pacte pour le gaz qui allait depuis
chez eux puisque ledit le gisement du
qatar est aussi un gisement iranien est
plutôt agissements iranien la plus
grande partie est sous l'iran et le
qatar il a fait un forage à 45 degrés
pour aller chercher de l'autre côté le
les iraniens voulaient faire un pas qui
allait aller jusqu'à la méditerranée
faire un port en méditerranée un port
méthanier et qui aurait permis donc aux
bateaux de venir chercher du gaz iranien
évidemment les compagnies qui avaient
kiné qui ne voulait surtout pas les
compagnies pétrolières et gazières ne
voulait surtout pas plaisir agnant face
à
et en particulier les gens les gens
d'arabie saoudite et du qatar donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé les deux
propositions ont été faites à bachar
bachar a choisi la solution iranienne
pour une raison qui me paraît évidente
c'est que import ça amène plus
d'activités quoi des royalties sur un
pipe qui passe donc il savait que c'est
bon et le résultat c'est alors c'est une
pure coïncidence bien sûr mais quinze
jours après les troubles ont commencé
comme ça pure coïncidence
partouche
alors tartous et les russes 7 les russes
cette chose les russes c'est très
intéressant ce qui est passé en syrie
parce que on a mal compris mal comme on
l'a mal compris en affaires de crime et
d'ailleurs les russes ils ont une base
en méditerranée c'est tartous pire que
tout toute la flotte tout ce qui est oui
la flotte russe ne peut faire escale en
méditerranée sans problème pour la
maintenance ravitaillement aux cathares
tous donc tartous pour eux il faut pas y
toucher donc quand la guerre a commencé
en syrie
les russes ils ont pas bougé parce qu'
il dise est un problème entre eux qui se
règlent leurs comptes entre eux poutine
était pas copain de bachar il n'était
pas du tout il y livre est quand même
des armes un poutine en battant dès 10h
heure et bachar ne paye jamais les armes
mais ça non mais que poutine est
considéré que sur le plan politique il
était intéressant d'avoir des liens avec
bachar comme mais je vous rappelle que
les israéliens avaient aussi des accords
avec bachar jusqu'au moment où il ya eu
les attentats contre le premier ministre
contre hariri il y avait aussi un accord
sur le liban entre entre bachar et son
père et puis les israéliens et ça se
passait très bien ils étaient tous
d'accord pour dire on contrôle à nous
deux on contrôle le liban ça gênait
personne
oui et les russes pendant ce temps-là
équiper les syriens sale et laid et des
américains équipés israélien il y avait
aucun problème
quand ce qui s'est passé après c'est que
les russes ont vraiment réagi alors là
militairement je dirais non pas en
fournissant des armes comme tous les
autres fourni ces armes à tout le monde
le
ça s'est passé d'une autre manière c'est
que les russes ont dit si vous devenez
si les groupes djihadistes
viennent à portée de tir
de tartous et met en danger la sécurité
est notre base alors là on va réagir si
vous pouvez reprendre ils l'ont déclaré
ils ont en plus ils n'ont annoncé c'est
pas du tout un truc ben ils l'ont
annoncé et effectivement quand une
partie des rayés jihadiste a commencé à
s'approcher beaucoup trop de là les
russes ont commencé à ce moment là à
prendre parti militairement en
commençant à agir si en amenant leurs
troupes leurs avions et autres c'est
très clair c'est bien on peut pas on
peut pas dire que les russes se sont
mêlés de cette affaire
jusqu'au temps que la leur base n'a pas
été menacée par contre après alors là
par contre ils ont mis les moyens et là
on voit bien que poutine
là il en a profité
alors après y'a pas de doute dans la
mesure où cela lui a permis de tester
tous ces nouvelles armes et ça ça a été
aussi une grande surprise pour tout le
monde parce que personne les américains
l'ont reconnu
personne ne pensait que l'armée russe
avait progressé ces dernières années
dans certains types d'armement ou subite
genre s 300 et 400 par exemple et
bientôt 1 500 way qui se révèlent une
arme terrible puisqu'on a neutralisent
pas
c'est une arme défensive mais j'ai pas
dis que c'est offensif mais c'est
défensif mais quand vous voyez pas mais
c'est très important si vous voulez
quand vous voyez par exemple qu'israël
envoie ses avions les avions israéliens
se baladent sur toute la zone parce
qu'ils ont ils sont équipés pour être
protégés sans aucun problème il faillit
ces dix étaient inatteignables je dirais
par les moyens d' attaque 22 contre
attaque ou de défense des pays les pays
autour bon là ils sont fait descendre un
avion et là là ça change complètement
les règles dieu les gens ne se rendent
pas compte mais la sphère de l'avion
israélien
au delà des rodomontades et tout ce
qu'on peut dire est très importante
parce que le message qui a été délivrée
aux israéliens c'est attention si vous
avez dans des zones qui sont défendues
par nos missiles vous avions passent pas
et ça change complètement les règles du
jeu
israël dans tout ça
by israel il joue un jeu un peu je crois
qu'il ya un jeu beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on ne veut le croire en dehors en
dehors de la sphère je dirais 30 piennes
de lévis de la vision trump yann de la
suite mais déjà israël israël joue un
drôle de jeu parce que d'un côté ils
vous disent on ne supporte pas l'iran
qui est notre ennemi mais il faut quand
même se souvenir que pendant la guerre
iran irak pendant que nous les français
on a provisionné saddam hussein en
armement et en avion de chasse
d'ailleurs
les israéliens de l'autre côté c'est la
langue est approuvée servait de relais
pour approvisionner en matériel
américain les iraniens alors que tout le
monde dit les iraniens et les américains
s'entendent pas ouais mais quand la
guerre iran irak c'est quand même
l'armée c'est quand même le matériel de
défense et d'attaqué américain qui a été
utilisé contre les irakiens qui a
utilisé des armes françaises donc si
vous voulez je crois qu'il faut être
très prudent là encore on est dans la
politique ils sont tous l'orient
compliqué moelleux les israéliens
huskies je pense moi surtout ils font
beaucoup beaucoup de bruit actuellement
parce que ils essaient de renforcer les
liens qu'ils ont avec
avec les états unis
d'autant plus que ces liens s'étaient
distendus à l'époque d'obama qui était
plus plus ouvert vers une évolution que
trump et maintenant avec train visé
c'est au contraire de se donner des
garanties pour en faire une forteresse
en effet le palestine
c'est un problème terrible parce que
je pense qu'il va folie l'autre depuis
le début on n'a pas voulu chercher une
vraie solution suivrait
qu'elles sont et telles
bain et ses traits dit c'est très très
compliqué parce que on coupe le fric à
tout le monde et puis je rentrerai
plusieurs erreurs d'abord quand on a
laissé croire on a laissé croire aux
palestiniens qui avaient été expulsés
qui pourrait revenir chez eux
c'était pas sérieux or depuis depuis
1948 on leur a laissé croire ça fait
quand même plus de 50 ans maintenant
qu'on leur a laissé croire qu'un jour
ils pourront revenir chez eux ce n'est
pas vrai mais d'un autre côté on peut
pas laisser des gens vivre dans des
camps parce que gaza c'est un camp c'est
pour une chose c'est un camp de réfugiés
et en plus très contrôlé quand
concertation ces légendes vivre comme ça
c'est peut-être un camp de concentration
non oui car sur certains points c'est
pas terrible quand on quand ils peur ils
vont voit bien que les conditions de vie
le problème des frontières ils peuvent
pas sortir sous des contrôles humiliant
ils peuvent pas y habiter bateau pelepas
chimiques qui peuvent pas les péchés
entassé ses anciens camps de
concentration
c'est pire qu'un ghetto un donc donc il
ya là il ya un problème de fond il faut
le régler alors voit ce que j'entends
c'est que trump eux dit je mets la
capitale je mets mon ambassade à
jérusalem parce que jérusalem soit la
capitale dix israéliens mais je vais
imposer une solution pour les
palestiniens et pour le moment je ne
sais pas laquelle je vois pas ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir imposer la turquie la
turquie la jordanie et les flux
migratoires ben la gestion jordanie elle
est aujourd'hui elle est le roi
d'ailleurs les rois parce que son père
était aussi est très efficace ils ont
réussi à faire une espèce de plateformes
qui est en définitive presque neutre la
jordanie elle est occidental mais elle
est pas trop quand même
elle voit elle voit passer tout le monde
sait que j'ai une sorte c'est un peu une
sorte de celui-ci voulait d'une certaine
manière elle a remplacé liban le liban
était la suisse du moyen orient un bon
maintenant vous me direz à dubai pour la
partie financière mais pour lens mais la
jordanie garde une position
personne n'a intérêt à ce que la
jordanie et des problèmes aucun des pays
autour d'intérêts parce que tout le
monde se sert de la jordanie comme un
lieu de rencontre comme un lieu
d'échangé des cuivres donc il faut
croire que la thur daniel va continuer
il n'y a pas de bon la turquie va on est
on est on est devant un devant un chef
d'état très malin parce qu'il est tout y
est tout sauf ou qui est effectivement
très proche des frères musulmans salade
sua pas maintenant on le voit il a il a
fait ce qu'on appelle en arabe la
taqiyya chez mais elle est à cacher la
réalité au départ pour être élu mais
maintenant on le voit bien alors on l'a
vu que sa femme avant l'élection à la
première élection sa femme n'avait pas
de foulard et dès qu'il a été élu
président il a fait mettre le foulard à
sa femme c'était clair la diva nancy
puis à peine de cacher on peut y aller
ce qui est qui est très intéressant de
ce que je pense la wii joue un jeu qu'il
faut regarder très près parce qu'on
attend ce on n'a pas tout le temps
savoir tous les codes les composantes
c'est que
il est les américains ont besoin de lui
les buy qui ont favorisé au départ sont
arrivés à faire pression sur l'europe
oui bien sûr exactement comme voilà
comme laquelle la sphère des balkans
c'est pour mettre un problème sur
l'europe
ça c'est clair mais ils ont ils ont
réagi je pense enfin là c'est vraiment
une opinion personnelle mais je pense
que le le complot gour le complot gaulle
qui a été fait qui a été annoncée et
dénoncé par un coup d'état le coût des
tentatives de coups d'état et
probablement au moins en partie vrai
c'est à dire que quand je pense qu'un
certain nombre de gens qui avaient aidé
à ce que erdogan prennent le pouvoir se
sont rendu compte qu'ils faisaient pas
du tout ce qu'on avait annoncé sivu
phillies ont essayé de renverser sa pas
marché et l'autre à utiliser sa très
intelligemment et très bien pour faire
le vide il l'a fait d'une main forte
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et après quand on regarde il est il est
il joue une politique à 3 à 3 pôles
parce que il dit aux américains vous
avez besoin de moi parce que vous avez
la plus grosse base la plus grosse base
américaine dans toute la zone hainaut
largement c'est la base qui est en
turquie où il ya la fois des stations
d'interception stations d'écouté une pub
base nucléaire il ya tout il ya les
avions il ya tout bon donc là il leur
dit moi je vous laisse là mais il faut
quand même respecter donc il me dirait
que les américains n'ont pas le choix
parce qu' aucune autre aucune autre base
y laisser construire des bases à doha ou
à djibouti mais c'est pas comparable et
puis s'est éloigné par rapport à la
russie
et à l'asie et à l'asie centrale le il
est en train de jouer avec les russes on
l'a vu puisqu'il veut acheter du
matériel des violences russe ce qui est
énorme puisque voilà un gars qui est
dans l'otan qui est qu il ya une base
militaire la plus grosse base une des
plus grosses bases militaires de l'otan
dans le monde et à côté de ça il va
acheter du matériel russe de défense
dont il ya quand même ça commence à
devenir compliqué puis confiance depuis
que le seuil est un petit peu active et
le jouer chez lui c'est ça moi je pense
moi je pense qu'il n'a pas confiance et
qu'ils y pour que joue sur les deux
tableaux mais il est en train de jouer
sur un troisième tableau aussi c'est
l'iran où il est en train de dire et on
l'a vu un il fait il est en train de
régler le problème de la syrie avec
l'iran
les russes mais les russes ont pas
vocation de rester à part sur leur zone
c'est clair à part sur la zone des deux
militaires sur la zone militaire mais il
est en train de régler le problème avec
les avec les iraniens et en définitive
avec les iraniens ils sont tous les deux
d'accord pour dire trop surtout pas que
les kurdes bouge plus que dans la zone
dira qu'il aura été à firhill a été
attribué george mitchell 10 temps libre
à moi j'ai croisé ici aura peut-être la
petite zone là actuelle l'actuel si vous
voulez dans la partie irakienne mais
pour le reste ni les iraniens ni les
turcs ne veulent une tuerie un kurdistan
ligne encore moins un kurdistan ils ont
accès à la mer parce que toute la sphère
actuelle c'est une tentative des kurdes
pour aller jusqu'à la mer et là on a vu
que les américains les occidentaux tout
le monde est laissé tomber et qu'urbain
c'est à dire c'est alors on dit c'est
scandaleux et tout mais c'est parce que
dans la politique géopolitique mondiale
c'est clair que le kurdistan d'accord à
condition qu'ils restent dans la zone
nord de l'irak et surtout pas ailleurs
on s'attarde un peu sur des shs so cool
des ch
je vous laisse commencé et je vous
titille un peu oui bien sûr allez c'est
parti
dai et voulait c'est
bon j'ai d'abord die je pense qu'on a là
encore
c'est quand même c'est nous nous sommes
en grande partie responsable de ce qui
s'est passé sur neige parce que
quand on voit toute l'histoire la montée
en puissance un de dèche bon c'est quand
même le résultat d'un côté de ce qui
s'était passé défunt c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec moussaoui c'est à dire avec
le
réel et les dirait les islamistes
radicaux qui avait dans le nord de
l'irak
c'est la continuation c'est pas une
nouveauté si vous voulez le plus le plus
violent de tous les djihadistes c'était
moussaoui c'était mais il avait été
d'ailleurs en afghanistan et en
afghanistan ben laden n'en voulait pas
ils en voulaient pas parce qu'ils le
trouvaient la mairie et le bagad elle le
trouvait trop violent
parce qu'ils étaient il faut bien voir
il était à christ et les takfiris 10 on
peut tuer y compris les musulmans alors
que les autres les salafistes vous dire
on ne tue pas les musulmans on tue tout
ce qui n'est pas musulman on tue pas les
musulmans c'est un moyen pour les
différencier des airs
il reste un moyen un peu terrible
notamment
le ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on les a
lésés faire nous on a on a laissé vous a
laissé faire ou on les a aidés
nos relations avec l'arabie saoudite le
qatar sourire revient à la raison le on
à dire qu'on a laissé faire on allait on
a laissé monter
cette machine de guerre quand c'était
une machine de guerre sans réagir sans
prendre le problème dès le départ parce
qu'en définitive nos intérêts va les
intérêts que nous percevions au niveau
du qatar au niveau de l'arabie saoudite
en particulier
faisait qu' on disait bon c'est une zone
désertique c'est dans un pays qui va pas
bien du tout allez c'est pas grave
et ça va très loin parce que on les a
laissés s'enrichir dans un premier temps
souvenez vous quand des chats commencé à
mettre la main sur les puits de pétrole
et les zones de production de coton et
bien il vendait il envoyé des camions il
y avait des colonnes de camions qui
partait de chez des skis par coban est
remonté sur la turquie où ses terres
vendues à des compagnies qui achetait le
coton ou acheter le pétrole à 200 étages
compagnie des compagnies pétrolières
c'était forcément des compagnies
occidentales qui achetait le pétrole
brut qui l'emmenait se faire raffiner
landerneau raffinerie
et oui et oui et ça explique pourquoi
ça explique pourquoi quand il ya eu
pendant toute la première partie de la
guerre en irak on ne bombarde pas les
colonnes de camions de pétrole qui
allaient 20 la turquie avec un argument
qui était quand même incroyable fouette
europe occidentale pour y croire c'est
l'humanité qui est l humanitaire on ne
tient pas sur les chauffeurs parce que
ce sont des civils
oui c'est énorme c'est do ré c'est beau
alors quand il ya eu quand on a eu les
russes sont arrivés eux qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait et russe ils n'ont pas hésité
ils ont tout de suite commencé à taper
sur le nerf de la guerre l'argent donc
ils ont détruit les convois de camions
paix de pétrole et l'écueil convoi de
camions de coton il faut pas oublier que
coton rapporter beaucoup d'argent aussi
et puis les antiquités parce que là
encore quand on vous dit on a fait
sauter les sites et autres mais faire
sauter les sites s'est pas uniquement
pour les détruire je vous avouerai que
je verrai des morceaux et pour les
ventes dans les années 80 y quitter et à
des collectionneurs particuliers bah oui
mais ça marche ça rapporte de l'argent
certains dont certains gouvernements
justement à ça je peux pas vous dire les
gouvernements mais moi ce que je suis
certain c'est que ça rapporte et ça a
mené et sont incertains et quand les
russes ont eu ou ont réussi à arrêter
les camions de pétrole le résultat a été
immédiat dèche a réduit la solde des
jihadistes les combattants des shows ont
vu leur salaire diminuer de manière très
importante ce qui a réduit l'entousiasme
parce que dans ces histoires là il ya
toujours l'argent ça compte y compris
pour les militaires
et des suspicions de
collaboration de
lafarge avec des shs
dgse votre avis un rôle là dedans
j'ai du mal à y croire j'ai entendu
comme tout le monde on a entendu en
alliant présomption d'innocence mathias
voilà exactement on ne peut pas savoir
il faut attendre moi personnellement ça
me semble étonnant sur moi je crois
plutôt que c'est un mois je peux me
tromper la ville a tjs ou qui était
dessus alors attendez que que les que
que les gens qui étaient que les
français de lafarge qui étaient là bas
et qui savaient donc ce qui se passait
et donner des informations et des gens
qui leur demandait j'espère que ça s'est
passé comme ça mais c'est pas ça veut
pas dire que la dgse a favorisé ou moins
encouragés à maintenir la chose si vous
quand vous avez des informateurs les
informateurs vous les avez pas ce que
vous apercevez quelqu'un est bien placé
peut vous donner des informations
vous voyez on vous ne peut pas imaginer
un service comme la dg se dire à des
sociétés extérieures et privés vous
allez garder une usine en plus par une
petite usine vous allez garder une usine
en marche de manière à avoir des
renseignements ça c'est pas possible
par contre qu'ils en aient tiré partie
j'espère qu'ils en usent j'espère qu'ils
ont usé d'informations parce que sinon
c'est dommage j'ai vraiment ils sont
celles où tu as loupé tout vous étiez en
poste ça vous est déjà déjà arrivé de
planter une source ou l'honorable
contributeurs
ah non je crois que c'est raide je pense
que c'est très grave
et très grave pour une raison très
simple c'est une question d'efficacité
si vous avez une source vous vous perdez
une source
vous ne pourrez plus à voir dans cet
environnement là d'autres sources parce
que tout le monde dira vous ne tenez pas
vos engagements que vous n'êtes pas
fiable et ainsi de suite ç'a changé
notre nom
bah il ya des trucs à des déclarations
d'un président de la république
française par mois qui akyé dans un
livre où ils vous racontent beaucoup de
choses sur lesquelles effectivement on
peut se poser des questions parce que
dans certaines choses qui ont été dites
pour des professionnels on peut remonter
à qui peut être la source de
l'information
et ça c'est très très grave ciment le
problème un service de sécurité ne peut
vivre que si les gens qui lui
fournissent les informations la
certitude qu'ils sont protégés et bien
sûr pour les services d'en face le jeu
c'est essayer d'identifier où les
sources ou d'amener le service à donner
ses sources c'est ça c'est des
retournements et tout ce que tous ces
jeux un peu tordu le dans dans
l'allée les français sur la syrie il est
certain que les français ont été là la
décision française
d'arrêter l'ambassade de russie
d'arrêter tout contact avec la syrie a
été une erreur colossale
puisque les autres sont restés
si vous voulez sous une forme ou sous
une autre les allemands les les
américains tout le monde a gardé des
contacts
et nous nous on a tout arrêté dans à
partir du moment où vous n'avez plus le
moyen de voir les moyens de voir ben
vous êtes en grande difficulté 1 pour
anticiper ou ne pas anticiper donc si on
peut plus anticipé mon père à bâle et on
l'est pas on perd toute efficacité dans
le monde actuel si vous n'êtes pas qu'un
leur différence et vous avez perdu la
guerre qu'on a le droit de perdre mais
on n'a pas le droit de se faire
surprendre cvc bonaparte
on en fait un autre comme ça oui le
renseignement c'est un métier de roi
fait à pense à vous et c'est un métier
de we dance est un métier de voyou fait
par des seigneurs c'est un métier de roi
fait par des truands dans c'est le
contraire c'est le contraire et c'est le
général commandant les services secrets
allemands qu'ils avaient sortis le
premier après ça a été on a on l'a mis
ça sur le dos de canaris ensuite on a
dit que c'est l'amiral canaris ce
qu'avait dit ça on était c'était durant
la première guerre mondiale mais mes
jeux comme a personnellement pour avoir
commenté un petit peu ce genre de ce
métier si je peux dire est ce jour là
mais si on voulait bah oui exactement
moi je dis que c'est ça le camp quand
c'est bien fait c'est pour ça que moi d
quelqu'un pour de marange par exemple
pour moi était un exemple de ce que
c'est qu'un patron de services de
renseignement parce que c'était un
seigneur mais il était capable de
comprendre d'utiliser des moyens de
boyoud mais toujours en gardant la
distanciation qui fait qu'on ne tombe
pas dans le système
comment vont les services de
renseignement français votre avis en ce
moment avec
quelques petites fusion quelques petites
écoutes de la nsa qu'avec une petite
partage de renseignements est ce qu'on
est vraiment pharmaco dépendant des
états unis ce que les renseignements de
terrain on s'est un petit peu assis
dessus je crois que si vous voulez parce
que les services de renseignement sont
devenus
on va dire la femme de ménage du pouvoir
politique
non non non non non non je pense que
s'ils voulaient la l'évolution des
services de renseignements occidentaux
je parle des occidentaux
l'évolution des services de
renseignement tient essentiellement au
fait qu' on s'est mis à utiliser de plus
en plus la technique au détriment du
reste du renseignement humain
renseignement humain parce que la
technique c'est moins risqué
oui faire une interception vous risquez
rien envoyé un type sur le terrain ou
une femme sur le terrain qu'elle se fait
prendre c'est pas du tout la même chose
donc si vous voulez c'est ça le truc
donc on a c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'écouter quelqu'un sur son portable que
de le tamponnais pour qu'il vous raconte
avec les moyens les moyens classiques
pour 6 classes hirsch tous les moyens
qu'on peut avoir l'argent l'idéologie le
sexe tout l'écart est jégo les carrés de
sucre et la torture
dont la torture ça marche pas si bien
que ça
nous aiderait torture vous savez vous
avez été formé une attention comment non
moi je vais pas été format la torture
ont valu ce qu on est on est tous
confrontés au problème d'une manière ou
d'une autre le problème vous savez il ya
un hic ça c'est très intéressant c'est
ce qui s'est passé que les américains
les américains ils ont torturé
officiellement vous savez et pas
seulement à guantanamo pendant les
prisons secrètes ils ont torturé mais
vraiment à un point qu'on imagine par
suivre khaled cheikh mohammed le gars
qui avaient même le gars qui avaient
monté l'opération des détours 292
waterboarding
enfin on dit on sait pas exactement mon
enfant on passe largement la centaine
quand vous pensez que nous on a raconté
au los résistant en france quand il
était face à barbie allions passer 5 10
fois drian disait c'est une horreur
absolue qu'est ce qu'on peut penser de
gens qu'ils émettent pendant 100 200
fois bon et mais c'est pas ça qui est
intéressant ce qui est intéressant cette
affaire-là passer les rapports qui sont
sortis derrière et qui ont montré que
quand les américains avec les bons ont
été solides quand les américains
commencé à appliquer une torture
systématique et très dur les gens ne
parlaient plus
et ça c'est très important et moi c'est
une conviction j'ai personnellement
c'est que dans la plupart des cas la
grande partie des cas surtout si vous
tombez sur les gens intelligents sur les
chefs si je peux dire les gens parlent
après il parle à partir du moment où
vous trouver la clé qui font qu'ils vont
pas tout vous dire mais ils vont vous en
dire suffisamment pour que vous puissiez
reconstituer et là on est plus dans la
torture et c'est beaucoup plus efficace
on est dans la collaboration
bah oui mais c'est
vous savez un c'est ça peut être assez
souvent efficace
la petite question internet de notre
communauté qui était en train d'ailleurs
de nous faxer qui en direct ont leur
passé un petit coup les gars et les
filles
l'indépendance des services de
renseignement français et comment la
dgse a pu passer à côté des écoutes
américaines sur sarkozy sur chirac sur
nos présidents
je crois que je suis pas tout bien fait
en fait ouais voilà j'allais vous dire
c'est pas on n'est pas passés à côté
tout le tautou services de renseignement
ainsi peut avoir si peu si la ci dispose
d'un moyen d'écouter ce que dit l'autre
en face c'est quand même plus sympa
c'est comme dans les films de cow boys 1
si vous jouez au poker avec vous et
mettre une glace dans le dos de votre
adversaire vous avez toutes les chances
de gagner
c'est pareil donc si vous voulez les
services ils essaient toujours d'avoir
avec leurs moyens d'avoir des
informations alors c'est vrai que il ya
eu un scandale en europe quand on s'est
aperçu que les américains saluent la
fuite avec snowden avec ce noël on s'est
aperçu que des américains écoutait tous
les chefs d'état il écoutait
ben zhang et la merkel il écoutait le
président sarkozy est jamais entreprise
est fière de cette surprise et tolérance
zéro ça mais c'est pas il faut être si
vous voulez fleur bleue pour croire
qu'on ne savait pas qu'ils aient goûté
on les a pris en flagrant délit à
l'époque de à l'époque c'était un genre
de la laisse ça à l'époque de thomson il
y avait une sombre affaire un contrat
qu'on négocier un an au brésil un
contrat sur les radios sur des systèmes
de radio pour le mato grosso l'homme
l'amazonie au brésil eh ben on s'est
aperçu que les américains avaient
intercepté toutes les communications
entre le siège de thomson à paris et les
négociateurs au brésil et ce qui fait
qu'à la fin aux surprise générale c'est
pas nous qui avons gagné le contrat
c'était les américains donc si vous
voulez c'est pas des nouveautés ceux qui
vous disent c'est incroyable les bras
vous en tombent pas ce que c'est c'est
pas possible on le sait depuis très
longtemps quand on voit quand on voit
des agents
de terrain se fait rigoler à cause de
leurs montres connectés ah oui là
histoire guerre sainte oui mais ça ça ça
montre qu'on amateurisme
me gênerait pas amateur il veu diret
méconnaissance amateurisme amènerait
d'accord mais c'est le destin matrix
mais ça vient d'une méconnaissance des
nouveaux outils
alors et ça paraît invraisemblable mais
c'est invraisemblable alors
ils ont été flagellées oui non mais
attendez lcc mais je pouvais tranquille
que maintenant ça se reproduira plus
parce que là ça lui ça lui laisse en
cascade avec des instructions à tout le
monde en disant maintenant vous arrêter
aux bêtises
mais vous savez yahia regarder un peu
comme le parc windows sur nos bateaux
ça le fait qu'on soit équipé de windows
oui
c'est l'amateurisme ou cesser la
corruption passive quand on voit un
cadre de l'armée française quitté
l'armée y aller bosser chez windows sans
respecter la commencer une période de
carence et non mais là c'est un problème
là c'est un problème que vous posez qui
est un vrai problème de fond mais c'est
un peu sous moi c'est ce que bon qu'on a
à certains appellent le pantouflage
l'autre pub en mai levage de sabots
ouais vous êtes son âge de saint brice
et aussi mais le fait le fait
effectivement c'est une vraie question
est ce que des gens qui ont été mêlés à
certain nombre de choses peuvent
sérieusement
travailler dans des conditions avec des
gens qui ce mot dans un environnement
qui pose dès qu'ils posent qui peut
poser des problèmes problèmes de
sécurité pour tous ceux avec qui ils ont
travaillé avant problèmes de sécurité de
cours
reims et des vraies questions et sur
lesquels honnêtement on n'a pas de
réponse parce que nous avons nous sommes
fin n'a pas de réponse il n'y a pas de
réponse légale
illégale maynial tatane un une bonne
tatane ça marche pas ça à défaut c'est
peut-être pas mal
on va se balader sur d'autres sujets
l'économie l'intelligence économique
vous avez un prisme de lecture sur la
fin du dollar ou la fin de l'euro ou où
les bulles qui explosent ou
l'interception renseignements dans les
entreprises où on se lance comme ça
je pense que
[Musique]
je pense que nous sommes en train
d'assister aux prémices de la fin du
dollar comme monnaie de référence ça va
prendre 20 ans et le rouge dans tout ça
alors ça c'est autre chose mais l'euro
sera si vous voulez le rose ce sera
ça sera impacté d'une manière ou d'une
autre par ce qu'il va se passer quand le
dollar
c'est certain que nous sommes
aujourd'hui depuis brétenoux d'un depuis
la fin de la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale nous sommes avec le dollar
comme référent et on en parlait tout à
l'heure on l'a imposée pour le pétrole
on impose pour un certain nombre de
choses et les américains utilisent ça va
très loin puisqu'il utilise dans le
cadre des lois extraterritoriales je les
joue d'utiliser le dollar vous êtes
passible des lois américaines donc je
sais ce
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
qu'un certain nombre de pays sont en
train de dire c'est pas normal que nous
soyons obligés de travailler en dollars
alors que le dollar nous ne pouvons pas
contrôler sa valeur puisque c'est les
américains qui décident de ce qu'ils
font avec le dollar et donc on a vu les
pays émergents avant la d'avant la
dernière crise on a vu les pays
émergents créer une banque une heure une
organisation financière qui se veut un
moyen terme l'équivalent du fmi mais à
effet mais qui serait dans les pays
émergents bon ça marche pas très bien
pour le moment oui mais parce qu'il ya
une crise économique inquiète qui a
perturbé ces pays là mais dans ces pays
là il y avait la chine
or la chine est en train de devenir la
première puissance mondiale et ça
personne ne veut en parler sérieusement
aujourd'hui elle est déjà la première
puissance mondiale au niveau des
réserves financières elles contrôlent
plus 30 % des bons du trésor américain
dire qu'elle peut mettre en difficulté
l'économie américaine tout moment
ça c'est clair ils ne font pas parce que
c'est pas leur intérêt pour le moment
mais le jour où ils vaudront ippon
et surtout dans les cinq ans à venir
elle va devenir la première puissance
mondiale tout court c'est à dire en pib
en tout ce qu'on a donc à partir de ce
moment là quand vous êtes le leader
mondial et que ça plus et on le voit en
2030 avant 2030 dans le dos vers 2025 on
devrait avoir largement plus de 50%
d'économie mondiale fait en asie
car c'est considérable le changement
n'allait le contournement est énorme
qu'est ce qui va se passer en plus ils
sont inclinés qu'est ce qui va se passer
oui donc qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire ils
vont dire dorénavant on va commencer à
imposer notre monnaie comme monnaie de
référence et imaginez si les chinois
disait à partir de maintenant toutes les
opérations avec la chine se font en lan
ben alors vent les états unis la césure
entre en crise
et alors et c'est 16 et s'assureront
s'ouvrir nous dans la politique de
briser en train qui se replient la
doctrine de monroe le repli sur
l'amérique du nord
l'indépendance énergétique gas grâce au
gaz de schiste qui leur permet de dire
venez chez nous
l'année sionisme total oui mais tout ça
est une puissance militaire qui
maintiennent pour pouvoir taper quand
ils veulent mais je pense que ça ne
suffira pas par rapport à cette montée
inexorable de la chine et et nous les
européens justement lors d'un jeu
revient à l'euro la question vous aviez
sur l'euro qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer
comme solution là dedans on voit les
américains qui peu à peu vont perdu de
bois quoi qu'ils en disent et quoi
qu'ils fassent ils essaient de retarder
bien entendu mais c'est eelv ont perdu
des points les chinois eux vont monter
cette inexorable exactement le même même
chose que pour les américains nous au
milieu si on est suffisamment gros en
europe pour pouvoir peser sur le plan
économique ou d'un côté ou de l'autre en
fonction de nos choix on peut exister et
l'euro peut exister à ce point là comme
monnaie complémentaire dans un sens ou
dans l'autre mais si on n'est pas fichu
de se mettre ensemble et qu'on continue
à jouer chacun pour soi
là on est mort et le rhône est bloquée
raison d'exister le secret d un faire ça
vous parle pas beaucoup qui vient de
passer son tour discute un peu avoue
volontiers parce que c'est un sujet que
j'aime beaucoup parce que en 2004 2005
j'ai essayé de faire passer la première
le premier texte sur le secret des
affaires à l'assemblée je me suis planté
mon successeur a essayé de faire passer
un deuxième texte il s'est planté et
c'est la seule elle l'europe qui a
réussi à s'épanouir en europe ils ont
fait passer donc à bruxelles à la
commission européenne et puis au
parlement ils ont fait passer un texte
sur une circulaire sur le secret des
affaires que maintenant les français
vont devoir appliquer puisque donc je
mords moi je m'en réjouis parce que je
pense que
si vous voulez
on une société ne pas ne peut pas être
totalement transparente
je vais bien même nom et vous donner un
exemple personnel c'est la moustache ou
le grand oral qui part non pas du tout
si vous vivez avec quelqu'un d'autre
quel qu'il soit et que pendant huit
jours l'un et l'autre
vous dit tout ce qui vous passe par la
tête sans rien cacher ce n'est pas à moi
ça fait 50 ans mais si vous dites mais
justement si vous dites tout ce qui vous
passe par la tête
au bout de huit jours ça explose
ça vous pouvez essayez vous verrez
c'est le problème de la transparence par
contre ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout
cacher tout le problème du secret des
affaires après tout si un ultime message
pas le mensonge par omission oui j'ai
des fois il vaut mieux ne rien dire
s'agit pas de mentir mais il vaut mieux
ne rien dire que de dire la vérité ça
c'est un principe mais aussi il ya plein
de choses qu'on peut dire si vous les
lettres la transparence elle doit
exister sur énormément de choses mais il
ya des domaines qu'il faut absolument
protéger lesquels bain dans une
entreprise par obs et les recettes faire
les recettes oui c'est les recettes par
exemple c'est les recettes ça c'est très
important c'est les conditions d'un
contrat qui vont vous permettre ce qui
peut si ces détenus par l'adversaire lui
permettre de vous tuer
est-ce que ça ça fracasse pas un peu le
travail de journaliste d'investigation
ignorant le sable ans lorsque je salue
les expose pas des poursuites
de deux chefs d'entreprise pas trop
content qu'on met sur la place publique
leur business un peu sulfureux alors
attendez je ne suis pas moi j'ai buzzé
pas dit qu'il fallait tout cacher loin
de là lahlou est tellement vague qu'on
plupart des missions et c'est là le
problème c'est qu'il faut peut-être
qu'on fasse une loi plus précise cet
autre chose il faut qu'on soit
suffisamment précis pour donner
effectivement des garanties aux
journalistes pour leur enquête qu'on
donne des garanties au vrai lance world
alerte parce que dans l'ensemble est à
trois catégories 1 js utilise la vérité
parce qu'ils sont scandalisés il faut
les aider il ya se venger de leurs chefs
ou de leurs adjoints ou deux trucs alors
cela il faut pas laisser quand c'est
beaucoup plus grave parce que c'est du
règlement de compte c'est de la délation
et puis les troisièmes ceux qui sont
payés par l'adversaire parce qu'on a
aussi et ça c'est très grave
il y en a beaucoup
donc si vous voulez il faut là encore
lens ordonné moi c'est le reproche que
je fais à la loi le leur sur la loi ce
que j'ai dit dès le premier jour je dis
bon qu'on favorise les lanceurs qu'on
aide les lanceurs d'alerté oui mais
mettez des règles pour que ceux qui ne
sont pas de vrais lanceur d' alerte par
contre les sanctions soient suffisamment
dissuasives pour qu'ils soient pas
tentés de le faire mais de temps en
temps le dimeet étaient nues quand même
dans tabac c'est tout c'est tout le
problème là c'est la justice car vous
quand vous êtes à la limite c'est la
justice qui peut le décider
vous avez confiance en la justice
française
tu as des plans on en discute
si vous voulez je pense que la justice
elle fait elle fait ce qu'elle peut
c'est pas souvent très facile parce
qu'elles ont des conditions de travail
sont pas toujours très bonne c'est fait
à dessein
non je pense que c'est ce dont je pense
que le l'état le politique a
insuffisamment pris au sérieux les
problèmes de justice peut-être pas envie
qu'on vit lui chercher des poux et
peut-être cette partie du problème mais
mais
mais mel je crois que le fond du
problème si vous voulez c'est que la
justice elle est aujourd'hui on voit
bien elle est complètement engorgé
elle est engorgé par des quantités de
choses qui n'existaient pas ayaz il faut
voir aussi à par rapport à il ya 30 ans
ou 50 ans il ya plein de choses qu'on ne
faisait pas on n'allait pas en justice
pour n'importe quoi aujourd'hui on est
une société qui s'est américanisée et
dans lequel ils diraient les un nombre d
affaires par exemple l'avocat doit être
à côté de vous en permanence mais chez
les militaires aussi maintenant les
militaires quand ils sont en opération
il ya un type qui vérifie qu on respecte
les textes de loi et autres le fameux 7
pour cent de perte par isa 30 % ou 7
pensons l'attrition c'est plus que j'ai
passé 2 % heureusement c'est insensé le
parapente ouais non c'est pas la même
chose
à son genou donne à ce que ce nous donne
il faut lui accueilli faut l'accueillir
en france et le protégé de tout avec
tout notre histoire
nos dance est un c'est un os et si vous
laissez
moi je pense que ce dell a eu un immense
mérite c'est que il a ouvert les yeux de
beaucoup de gens sur des réalités que
les gens ne voulaient pas croire ceci
dit une bonne partie ont lu ce que
disait snowden y croient toujours pas
donc ça c'est encore il faut être
réaliste c'est des crétins ou c'est
simplement des gens dans le déni non
c'est le déni
c'est le déni c'est pas possible
c'est exagéré c'est pas possible qu'on
cela fasse m 1 par notre ami m'a par
exemple
ouais on dit c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible alors que tous les gens le
savent c'est pas c'est pas un secret les
gens savent très bien il ya de bons
restos dance a pas été une révélation
les wikileaks avant on avait donné aussi
un certain nombre d'informations il ya
eu des fuites par moments c'était la
wind va attendez il ya eu il ya eu un un
des rares transfuge américain venu en
europe se plaît philippe el jai elle
parle de sa ya trente ans quarante ans
il avait commencé à expliquer ces choses
là aussi l'effet un livre où il avait il
avait raconté injustement les pratiques
certaines pratiques bon à l'époque dans
les services avait eu un succès
d'intérêt je dirai évidemment mais pour
le grand public c'est très loin des
problèmes du grand public faux et
honnête c'est très loin des problèmes du
grand public pourquoi parce que le grand
public n'a plus les capacités cognitives
de comprendre ce monde si complexe ou
est ce qu on les maintient l'état de
chatons les infantilisant
je pense qu'on a vendu l'isu et à mon
grand regret je pense qu'on a inventé
lisent les gens
on veut trop on veut on ne veut pas on
veut pas dire des choses qu'on ne prend
pas les gens vinci ne va rien pour
m'expliquer exactement
les générations actuelles avec les
moyens d'information monde disposent les
générations actuelles on est beaucoup
plus au courant des choses qu'il y a
vingt trente ou cinquante ans c'est
évident à tout point de vue d'ailleurs
on voit des documentaires qui fait qu'on
connaît le monde sans quitter son salon
ou sa salle à manger où sa chambre on
connaît le monde on a vu des films on a
entendu on a vu comment étaient les gens
et autres bons et à 50 ans il fallait
partir en bateau ou en avion ça m'a été
un temps fou il y avait des risques et
tout bon sur le plan sur le plan de ce
qui se passe des méthodes et c'est
exactement pareil il ya des livres qui
paraissent donc les livres sont souvent
très précis et donne plein
d'informations mais les gens lisent pas
si vous voulez les gens lisent peu en
définitive ils lisent des romans
mais là les dés la réalité les gens ne
lisent pas beaucoup la réalité
est pourtant la réalité c'est souvent
mieux que les romands entre parenthèses
on accueille snow de nous on n'accueille
pas
moi je pense qu'il faut laisser là où il
est pris les traits bien
parce que ça c'est qu'est ce que ça nous
rapporte rien ou je sais pas qu'on me
contre à la terre entière qu'on a encore
des rouges tout en france oui mais oui
mais tu allais je sais pas s'il a été
accueilli par et par les rues sous
lequel est passé par les russes et par
d'autres rappeurs de sciences aiguilles
en france non non non non lens on est
capable de le protéger en quand même on
est capable de protéger les gens france
blessures sur veulent protéger en
protège vous savez confiance dans un dg
et si oui pour ça oui pour d'autres
choses c'est ça voici un exemple pour ça
je sais qu'ils ont les hommes si vous
voulez il ya des choses si c'est des
problèmes techniques par exemple c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce qu'il faut
avoir le matériel si c'est à dire que le
d si un matériel que
obsolète non je suis en train de dire
c'est que je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui quels que soient les
efforts qui ont été faits s'il ya des
missions sur lesquels la dgsi a besoin
de s'appuyer sur d'autres
alors que sur le plan par des humains
techniques des hommes l'ady gil 6-1
personnel qui est parfaitement capable
de répondre aux missions
on parle un peu d'alstom pourquoi pas
alstom c'est quoi c'est un monsieur qui
s'est couvert en bradant de nos
entreprises pour éviter quelques
poursuites dans nos amis ou est-ce que
c'est autre chose
alors je crois qu'elles sont c'est une
affaire emblématique si vous voulez
c'est une c'est une opération
pour moi c'est une véritable opération
qui a été montée pour récupérer les
turbines
les turbines à gaz qui étaient quittées
dans les cas c'était le seul domaine
dans lesquels les français étaient
leaders mondiaux donc mais la france en
s on perd notre souveraineté dans ce
domaine là où il ya indiscutablement
c'est une perte de cela la ferraille
somme a été une perte de souveraineté
dans la sphère du turbine n'y a pas le
moindre doute là-dessus et c'est une
opération montée puisque quand on
reprend toute l'histoire si vous voulez
on voit l'utilisation des lois
extraterritoriales on voit les six les
écoute il y en a eu un on voit les
menaces sur les uns ou sur les autres on
voit la justice américaine envoie
quantité de choses et on voit des fake
news on voit de la manipulation
elle vous parle étant défectueuse moment
je me souviens du président de
lui président d'alstom faisant une
déclaration à la presse en disant notre
affaire non tout va très mal chez nous
il faut qu'on vendre parce que tout va
très mal dans notre affaire l'état bon
et puis une fois qu'on a vendu aux
américains le successeur a dit à la
première réunion financière à dinan
situation est très bonne de qui se moque
t'on
qu'est-ce qu'il fait face pendant était
sale comme on fait pareil place et
l'ajout vrai nom mais la justice
d'accord voyelles droit en douce action
piano droit romain oui mais il faut que
la vie vaut il voulait il faut que
l'état doit doit agir l'état mais
également la justice n'est pas devenue
une puissance de moyenne puissance oui
je suis bonne phrase
chinoise et bien comme ça ouais mais
pierre que j'aime beaucoup et qui est un
homme de grande qualité ça me donne pas
gagné ça mais il a raison il a raison le
nous avons nous avons des capacités mais
encore faut-il avoir la volonté suivre
mais je crois aussi qui a je reviens à
ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur 10 à
faire comme ça sur alstom moi ce qui m'a
frappé sur alstom c'est qu'en définitive
aux plus hauts échelons de l'état
les gens ne comprenaient pas ce qui se
passait donc si vous voulez là je dis je
le pense vraiment je pense que il ya eu
il ya eu des fautes de fait évidemment
mais c'est des fautes qui ont été je
dirais inconsciente parce que les gens
n'avaient pas compris ce qui passait il
a fallu que toute la sphère soit déroulé
ensuite une fois qu'elle était terminée
que toute la sphère sco déroulé pour que
ce qu'on disait avant les uns et les
autres en disant attention voilà ce qui
se passe les gens mettant tout bout à
bout 10 mais c'est vrai mais les gens
c'est le pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
politique est-ce qu'on est dirigée par
une bande de crétins arriviste
non mais je pense que c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya une
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a c'est paraît paradoxal
mais je pense qu'au niveau de l'état au
niveau des plus hautes des plus hautes
autorités de l'état par moment il ya une
certaine naïveté ou une consanguinité
possible aussi c'est pas possible c'est
grave voici fait quoi on fait quoi pour
récupérer une soirée mais c'est clair
que la vienne ici vous voulez quand on
prend par exemple les vous prenez les
grandes sociétés françaises
vous regardez les conseils
d'administration bon vous apercevez
qu'il ya des croisements dans tous les
sens bon les gens ils sont des mêmes
écoles ils sortent des mêmes écoles ils
sont des mêmes promotions il se retrouve
dans les mains dans les sociétés les 1
face aux autres bon vous allez pas
démolir le copain chez bob parce que
vous êtes administrateur sa société
alors que lui et qu'elle me satan de la
vôtre parce que sinon il va vous le
faire payer donc on voit qu'on a mis en
place dans le temps ça fait 25 ans que
ça s'est mis en place on a mis en place
des systèmes qui forcément mais nos
dysfonctionnements on fait quoi il faut
changer les règles là mais on fait comme
on peut changer lui répondait prend les
points là bas je pense qu'il faut il
faut qu alors là c'est le politique là
c'est vraiment des décisions politiques
de ce pays
oui non attendez je sais que c'est les
mêmes mais il faut justement espérer que
iana temps en temps ça arrive comme
ac/dc des incantations non non non non
non non je dis que j'étais optimiste
mais pas complètement idiot non plus
non je pense je pense qu'il y a dix ya
des gens qui ont la capacité qui ont
d'abord qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
éclairent la capacité d'imposer qui
l'armée
écoutez moi je vais pas je bats fort de
promotion politique de quiconque 1 mais
non non non mais attendez non non non
mais je vais vous dire je pense qu'il y
avait des gens moi je si je prends le
passé
de gaulle on pouvait l'aimé ou pas
l'aimer mais de gaulle is c'est genre de
truc qui savait faire
pompidou derrière quand il avait fait
aussi la effets des mutations très
importante un haut niveau de l'état
français bon il n'hésitez pas non plus
on a il ya eu des purges mais
spectaculaire à l'époque on s'en
souvient plus maintenant mais pourquoi
et pourtant c'était un banquier il
venait de chez rothschild bon mais
pourquoi il faisait pourquoi il faisait
ça et parce qu'il était convaincu qu'il
fallait effectivement moderniser que
s'il y avait des blocages il fallait
débloquer
je présente alors j'entends aujourd'hui
on me dit c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui
se passe c'est ce qui va se faire ou
c'est ce qui se passe j'ai j'espère
peut vivre d'espoir aussi
quand tu y tiens une volonté il ya un
chemin oui absolument
bon vent pour celui qui sait où il doit
la voir bref qui ose gagne c'est ça
voyais absolument
petite question internet les réseaux
gladio ça vous parle bien sûr on fait
pas trop longtemps mais au nom par la
has et donc l'otan qui crée des
attentats ici ou là il faut se remettre
parce que maintenant c'est facile dans
cet appareil pour beaucoup de gens ça
paraît une histoire ancienne de la
grande époque mais il faut se remettre
dans la position qu à la fin de la
guerre la deuxième guerre mondiale les
russes avaient réussi à descendre
jusqu'à berlin et il avait récupéré tous
les pays du nord de l'europe et puis la
chape de plomb était arrivé sur eux bon
l'occident sur et les occidentaux était
de l'autre côté mais tout le monde avait
peur sous il faut souvenir des
stratégies de l'époque tout le monde
avait peur que les russes à un moment ou
un autre décide de descendre plus loin
et de conquérir toute l'europe
continentale et un certain nombre de
gens le craignait sérieusement et
c'était dans tous les plans à la foule à
l'époque chez les militaires on parlait
de la trouille füle dans nord de
l'allemagne où les charrues salle et d'y
aller par des télés les chars les
chaouis les chars russes allaient
descendre un comme les armées de
guderian la deuxième guerre mondiale et
puis allez aller jusqu'à bordeaux ou en
espagne bon à ce moment là qu'elle est
la question qui s'est posée pour les
occidentaux c'est de se dire si jamais
ces gens-là descendre il faut qu'on
puisse monter des organismes de
résistance contre l'ennemi comme il y en
a eu pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
est plutôt que d'avoir à parachuter des
gens depuis les pays étrangers sur les
pays européens pour organiser cette
résistance montons ses réseaux de
résistance en avance c'est sale et
réseau gladio
c'est pas autre chose
alors ce qu'il ya c'est qu'ensuite en
italie il ya eu des dérives sur l'italie
parce que des gens ribeiro et rives
énorme dérive parce qu'il ya eu des gens
qui étaient dans ces réseaux qui sont
révélés des gens d'extrême droite à
l'époque
et qui ont fait des attentats c'est un
petit peu ce qui se passe à 5 le
terrorisme islamiste non
lui certaine manière peut-être aussi
et justement et si vous voulez et le
donc à partir du moment à l'époque c'est
ça se comprend dans l'est dans l'état
d'esprit de la guerre froide un il faut
bien souvent l'époque c'était
parfaitement justifié de dire il faut
qu'on se protège parce qu'on a le risque
qui débarquent tout le monde pensait que
ça pouvait arriver bon c'est vrai
qu'ensuite bon ben ça s'est éloignée de
plus en plus les problèmes on les a pas
vu de ce côté là mais plutôt de l'autre
est d'ailleurs à la fin ça s'est terminé
par l'effondrement du bloc de l'est est
pas du bloc de l'ouest a donc si vous
voulez c'est un foyer renversé qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand le chien mord la main
de son maître alors qu'on les a formés
financé on fait quoi
je vois bien un éclair de lucidité
traversée avait fait une bonne question
là ça vous rappelle l'un
des des histoires tout ça rappelle des
chauves souris ça rappelle des choses
je pense que moi je crois que
si vous voulez
le chien peut toujours mort de la main
de son maître
et là encore il faut se poser la
question est ce que c'est parce que le
maître a eu un comportement que le seul
élu lucien n'étaient pas préparés
et à ce moment là bas il faut pas
s'étonner si vous mort ou est ce que le
chien a été pris par un accès de folie
et là c'est un vrai problème il faut il
faut voir ce qu'il faut faire du chien
le
on a je pense mais je pense que souvent
ce qu'il ya c'est toujours la même
histoire
dans beaucoup de choses on ne va pas
assez loin dans la réflexion et dans
l'analyse dans la saga du neuf lui
renseignement qui vont pas baisser c'est
vraiment ça moi je suis frappé par le
dans le monde actuel en particulier par
l'absence de réflexion et d'analysé dans
l'instant si de résidence oui là aussi
la résidence a fait partie du problème
si vous voulez être résilient il faut
avoir analysé tous les facteurs il faut
savoir comment vous allez faire pour
résister si vous n'avez pas regardé
comment ça se passe si vous n'avez pas
vraiment analyser la situation
suivaient pas compris les tenants et les
aboutissants mais vous y arriverez
jamais et le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est dans cette dans ce
monde d'immédiateté où il faut décider
au jour le jour 1 le chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui dans les boîtes du cac 40
l'objectif c'est tous les trois mois
d'avoir de bons résultats pour les
analystes financiers
bon au mieux pour les autres c'est à la
fin de l'année mais si vous êtes chef
d'entreprise vous savez qu'on ne fait
pas une politique à trois mois ou un an
une politique d'entreprise c'est comme
une politique d'état c'est dans la durée
on travaille à 3 ans à 5 ans à 10 ans
comment ça se fait que
nous la france qui sommes censés avoir
une capacité de réflexion un petit peu
en dehors de la boîte on n'arrive plus à
faire de la prospective
à voir plus loin que le bout de notre
nez c'est à cause de ces élites
consanguine formé aux états unis par des
think tanks des influences de l'otan ou
c'est parce que tout simplement je vais
parler vulgairement on m'a perdue nous
couilles
les deux mon général
les deux alors si vous voulez quand
quand tu danses que lorsque vous dit il
il ya plusieurs choses il faut là aussi
la prospective c'est essentiel parce que
justement à des problèmes majeurs
d'aujourd'hui un quant au fait de
l'intelligence économique c'est ce qu'on
apprend aux gens leur dit vous voulez
vous définissez ce que vous voulez faire
ok ensuite vous définissez le cadre de
l'action sur ceux là où vous allez
chercher toutes les informations dont
vous avez besoin et une fois que vous
avez fait ça vous vous dites bon et qui
pourrait se passer dans dix ans dans 20
ans et là vous rajouter des éléments
nouveaux c'est de la prospective marc
ulmann dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
les veilleurs à son âme division et
guillaume robert était aussi faisait
partie de cette équipe c'étaient des
gens bien son panorama tous les deux
c'était des gens qui étaient justement
qui faisait de la prospective c'est à
dire que quand vous discutiez avec eux
l'événement d'aujourd'hui les
intéressait pratiquement pas les culs
des choux exactement l'écumé des jours l
écume des choses ce qui était important
c'était justement de détecter des
signaux faibles qui indique l évolution
dans dix ans dans cinq ans pendant 20
ans et dire tiens là il se passe quelque
chose
regardons je les connaissais bien j'ai
la chance d'être dans un groupe de
travail sur la réévaluation des intérêts
vitaux des états unis
et moi il me laissait faire l'expérience
de pensée ultime c'est à dire que l'on
n'avait pas de brides et on avait
l'opportunité de laisser divaguer nos
cerveaux pour pouvoir aller chercher en
dehors de la boîte mais il faut mais ça
se fait plus ah oui parce que on est
dans la pensée unique et que la pensée
unique vous empêche comme vous l'avez
dit comme les américains le think out of
the box les gens ne savent plus penser
en dehors de la boîte on est dans un cas
et pire encore si vous osez penser en
dehors de la boîte tout le monde vous
tombe dessus en disant salopards tu n'as
pas le droit alors que c'est pourtant en
dehors de la boîte que réside l'avenir
surtout dans un monde en évolution comme
celui d'aujourd'hui
selon du système éducatif ah oui qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec ce système
éducatif gangréné ben je pense qu'il
faut qu'on réapprenne d'abord aux
professeurs il faut qu'on leur apprenne
un certain nombre de réalités du monde
d'aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont
pas voulu voir on marche sur des chemins
on a supprimé la référence à l'histoire
j'ai écouté l'autre jour un éminent
professeur qui nous disait défend il est
l'histoire de la france a commencé en
1789 moi quand j'ai entendu ça je me
suis étranglé jeudi mais attendez vous
connaissez l'histoire de france ah oui
je suis mais attendez mais a quand même
plein de choses avant vous voyez pas que
les gaulois les capétiens les
carolingiens et tous les autres ils ont
pas ils ont pas contribué à la france
vous ça vous 10 ans pax voyez que c'est
arrivé comme ça uniquement avec
robespierre et l'être suprême enfin il
faut arrêter quand même ne serait ce que
ben boyer et mais
sait on ne ne veut pas alors on a d'une
part supprimé la référence à l'histoire
en l'histoire vous apprend beaucoup de
choses parce que l'histoire vous amène à
réfléchir
et buisine s'enracine c'est clair
les lettres ne s'enracinent l'arbre ne
peut pas pousser
donc on a besoin de nos racines et ses
racines sont essentiels il faut les
connaître il faut les comprendre bon et
puis derrière il faut aussi imaginer
l'avenir et si vous êtes capable de
joindre le passé et l'avenir alors le
présent paraît simple
c'est ça le 2 et c'est pour ça que la
prospective est essentiel parce que
c'est la vision du futur le passé parce
que vous pouvez en tirer les
enseignements hélas après bondi valable
le reste je vois comment je vais faire
or malheureusement par le fait de la
pensée unique par le fait de la manque
du manque de culture de nos concitoyens
alors qu'ils ont ils ont bon ils savent
beaucoup de choses si vous voulez par
les moyens modernes on s'est énormément
de choses on tape sur wikipédia ou
entament tout ce qu'on voudra ou sur un
moteur de recherche vous avez des
quantités d'informations tout de suite
mais c'est pas ça qui fait la
connaissance la connaissance il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin la connaissance
elle comprend le passé le présent et le
futur
c'est janus vous savez c'est janus des
romains où c'est le bateau mais des
templiers
la franc maçonnerie l on est où là avec
tout ça parce que la franc maçonnerie el
celler grise
à l'est pas morte mais elle est en crise
et en crise parce que justement elle à
el had elle a apporté des réponses la
franc maçonnerie au xviiie siècle elle a
apporté énormément de réponses parce
qu'elle a permis des échanges qui
n'était pas possible dans des systèmes
que des systèmes de dictature une
royauté c'est pas une n'est pas un
système totalement libérale donc pour
pouvoir parler les seuls endroits dans
lesquels les esprits pouvait changer
sans risquer de se retrouver en prison
c'était les loges donc ça ça a très bien
fonctionné en france en angleterre par
tout ça très très bien marché au xixème
siècle il ya eu la politique c'est a
commencé à se mêler beaucoup surtout
vers la fin du 19e siècle la politique
c'est beaucoup mais l'est de la france
de la maçonnerie en france on n'avait
que grand orient et la montée du grand
orient mais on l'a vu aussi chez les
anglais où ils ont développé
leur grande loge d'angleterre qu'il
était la référence mondiale mes
références mondiales ça voulait dire
instruments de colonisation la grande
loge d'angleterre a été le moyen pour
eux de contrôler tous les territoires du
commonwealth puisque les élites des pays
du commonwealth
étaient venait en horloge parce qu'ils
agissent avec il allait retrouver des
élites qui avait un échange ouvert mais
ça permettait aussi aux six aux anglais
le contrôle et en voyant qui était ce
qu'il fallait penser comment il était on
a fait la même chose avec l'afrique mais
bien sûr on l'a fait après coup nous ça
a été après mon à fait la même chose en
afrique la france en afrique la franc
maçonnerie implanté par les français a
joué exactement le même rôle que les
anglais dans la zone du commonwealth et
les zones dont il est doué anglophone
donc mais saad ça a duré un temps et ça
a permis de faire un certain nombre de
choses parce que c'est vrai il faut pas
tout voir malo bien au contraire ça a
aidé sûr à 100 de sa véhiculer un
certain nombre d'idées ça a permis de
faire avancer un certain nombre de
choses son nombre de valeurs mais
aujourd'hui le problème il est qu'on se
trouve dans un nouveau monde sa peau
était contreproductif de la françafrique
tout ça les débats comme toujours il ya
des terrils la dérive est toujours
propre contre-productive il n'y a pas eu
que des dérives si vous laissez ça si
vous voulez il ya eu ça a été aussi un
moyen de repérer les élites les gens de
valeur et de les faire monter en
puissance
ça c'est ce côté là ça a été très utile
alors il ya eu des dérives s'il faut pas
se leurrer un je vous parle je vais pas
vous dire le contraire les masses ont
encore un rôle à jouer
je pense que oui parce que c'est laid
parmi les derniers à défendre des
valeurs
ils sont pas eux mêmes
sous influence avec des déviances
c'est un problème avec des réseaux de
corruption ah oui mais ça c'est un
problème qu'on fait pour aller à la
chasse aux corrompus dans une loge c'est
pas facile pas facile à tous est la
doucette c'est pas mal non non parce
qu'on apprend la tolérance
mais elle apprend la tolérance mais mail
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que le
lia pas il ya plusieurs dangers dans les
loges il voulait il ya le danger de la
corruption chez les affairistes les gens
qui viennent en pensant que ça va leur
servir alors en france c'est ça n'a plus
beaucoup de valeur aujourd'hui saïss a
eu beaucoup de vin ça a été vraiment une
réalité
en tête sous la 3ème et la 4ème
république ça c'est clair
depuis sa bo énormément baissé taille a
pas de il ya le fantasme actuelle il
n'ya pas il ya pas grand chose parce que
pour une raison très simple d'ailleurs
c'est que ça fonctionne pas c'est très
cloisonné l'éloge d'une loge c'est un
petit nombre de gens alors ils se
connaissent bien cela ne me connaissent
pas les autres donc si vous laissez pas
si simple qu'on ne veut le croire
mais cette valeur de cette défense des
valeurs me paraît moi un élément positif
de nous donner en trois à l'internet par
exemple l'égalité la fraternité
la liberté je rajouterais la tolérance
c'est déjà pour moi c'est des valeurs
qui sont très importantes alors après il
ya d'autres valeurs qui sont des valeurs
qui mais là ça va plus loin si vous
voulez ses valeurs spirituelles c'est à
dire que
non enfin dans les dents là en
maçonnerie une bonne partie de la
majorité de la maçonnerie à 10,3 istres
et spiritualiste hindouistes ou non d
east pas justement un accent délicieux
nac sont pas des listes mais ceux qui
sont des listes qui sont plutôt c'est
plutôt ceux là qui sont pas vers la pour
la spiritualité
là on découvre très vite que par ce
qu'on appelle la transcendance la
recherche de la transcendance
où la compréhension de la tendance passe
par l'humidité donc l'humilité devient
une valeur les valeurs maçonniques ceci
dit je vous dis il faut pour ça
travailler et c'est pas le cas de tout
le monde font tous les ans à pierre
c'est sa
question internet le franc cfa point
d'interrogation le fait que des pays
africains souhaite s'en séparer le fait
que leur monnaie soit car je pense je
pense que la langue française si vous
voulez elle un avantage lors south
ilaria il ya ceux qui vont vous dira oui
mais c'est une langue coloniale non
c'est pas ça francs cfa excusez moi
j'avais compris le français d'abord
après le français peut aller vous
réponde aussi confus on verra ça plus
emballant alors sur le franc cfa oui
effectivement on peut se poser la
question les
les africains peuvent se poser la
question de savoir si le franc cfa
est quelque chose qui doit être
totalement indépendant du système de
notre système ou pas je crois qu'on y va
on va aujourd'hui si vous voulez vers
une d'une monnaie africaine de référence
ou des monnaies africaines de référence
et tout le monde ya intérêt si vous
laissez un peu comme l'euro l'euro c'est
vrai que c'est quand même bien pratique
en europe bon si on peut faire la même
chose en afrique et on l'a avec le franc
cfa mais il ya plusieurs types de vous
savez c'est un peu compliqué j'aimerais
qu'on aurait tout intérêt à avoir des
modes une monnaie qui soit utilisé par
tout le monde sera un avantage seulement
ça implique des règles de gestion
budgétaire des pays qu'il est très
difficile de faire appliquer en afrique
vous avez une opinion sur des crypto
monnaie le bitcoin pas jusqu'à
maintenant c'est la monnaie les voyous
c'est à dire la mode et des services de
renseignement non ah bah non non non non
c'est pas ça
là non donc il ya des bitcoins
attendait si le 6-1 services de
renseignements pensent de ces liens pour
financer une opération
ça peut être utile pour qu'elle ne
puisse pas repéré qu'il a fait
d'utiliser une opération bitcoin
pourquoi pas ça ça rentre dedans
justement dans les opérations dans le la
préservation du secret des opérations
des services mais moi ce que je dis sur
le bitcoin s'est jusqu'à maintenant le
bitcoin a été utilisé essentiellement
pour des opérations de fraude et autres
je ne dis pas que dans le futur ça ne va
pas évoluer pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que on a démarré le
bitcoin était la première - crypto
monnaie donc c'était bon tout le monde
découvrait un petit peu 1 voilà mais
maintenant les choses sont en train de
changer d'abord n'y a pas que le bitcoin
diatonique et voilà il ya toute une
série de cryptome onex en train de se
faire il ya encore les états commencent
à voir des systèmes de contrôle comme
les états unis sur le bitcoin pour le
oui mais ça c'est un projet ça parce
qu'à un moment contrôler rien du tout
aujourd'hui on commence à mieux
contrôler c'était le bon temps ah bah
oui à berlin mais attendez moi si je
suis ce qu'ils ont sur cru l'idée du
bitcoin en disant on sort des règles
nationale avec des monnaies contrôler
tout ça pour la liberté moi je dis c'est
pas c'était c'était une bonne idée hein
je suis pas en train de ce que je dis
c'est l'utilisation qui en a été fait ou
qui a été majoritairement fait dans la
première étape du beach boys qui étaient
majoritairement fait par des voyous qui
ont parfaitement compris tout l'intérêt
qu'ils avaient dû utiliser le bitcoin
pour vous c'est à nos amis qui viennent
nous chercher
pour vous un hacker c'est un pirate
c'est un corsaire comment ça se fait que
la france a craché sur les hackers
pendant 20 ans alors que nous amis
allemands les les dorloter il a dit à
nos amis serait il ya le sait bien le
manteau long dans leur cracher dessus
nous on a fait une vague chose pour
essayer de les contrôler à l'époque
mais je voyais d'abord je pense que
l'eac les hackers au départ c'est des
pirates ou du corsaire a pour moi
c'était pas des pirates au départ merci
non pas du tout ah non moi je porte mon
contraire ah non mais je vais achever
j'allais un peu plus loin là dessus
parce que je pense que c'est un vrai
dire il faut les jouer c'est qu'il verse
expliqué
au départ on l'était avec un outil
totalement nouveau on découvrait le web
le monde du web dark web il dit web le
web enfin découvrez tout ça on
découvrait le cyberespace bon que des
gens un pied qui avait envie de vivre
qui avaient envie c'est des aventuriers
dans le bon sens du terme ben ils ont
voulu découvrir ce que c'était que le
cyberespace comme les gars de colons
sont partis en amérique pour moi c'est
la même chose si vous voulez ou comme
les types sont partiront sont partis ou
partiront dans l'espace c'était c'était
d'une nouvelle terre à conquérir donc
les gens qui ont été là dedans ils ont
exploré une nouvelle terre à conquérir
je vais vous dire que ce sont des voyous
que ce sont les affreux et tout ça bon
après comme toujours dans la société
humaine quand il ya quelque chose qui se
crée y ait des petits malins qui dit
j'en profitais pour moi alors là il ya
une deuxième vague c'est la vague on l'a
vu pour le bilc oeil au départ l'idée
était marrante et puis après on est
sympa et puis après on voit les voyous
qui dit c'est super
me permet de faire des de récupérer de
l'argent sans l'europe sont de faire
repérer bon on a vu pour les pour les
hackers on les a vus aller très loin
dans les entreprises ou dans les états
dire pour aller chercher des choses pour
les six étaient et on et ça a été
utilisée à ce moment là par d'autres les
capacités des hackers de départ elles
ont été utilisées par des services de
renseignement qui ont dit on va te faire
travailler pour aller est rentré chez
les petits camarades d'en face elles ont
été utilisées par des voyous qui ont dit
si tu viens travailler pour moi tu vas
gagner beaucoup d'argent donc ce qui
était au départ une formidable aventure
comme toujours dans l'histoire du monde
il ya des gens qui sont fait récupérer
maintenant ce que je constate c'est qu'à
la fin de l'histoire quand d'un certain
nombre de pays
les hackers qui ont tourné mal je dirais
ceux qui ont tourné mal en général ils
sont pas me et techniquement parlant ils
sont même souvent très bon cela quand
ils se font prendre l'état a alors fait
un marché en leur disant
tu peux avoir du gros problème mais si
tu travailles pour nous en tant qu'etat
ça pourra s'arranger que c'est le film
will hunting alors j'ai pas vu celui-là
non celui qui dit hein pourquoi je ne
travaillais pas pour l'année ça oui
mais gêné vous vous devez recruter un
hacker lui dit quoi
à moi si je recrutais un cabas je
recruterai un hacker français 1 donc si
j'ai recruté un coeur j'ai un coeur
français je veux dire à écouter bon vous
allez vous amuser autant mais vous allez
faire dans l'intérêt national donc si
vous nécessaire pour toute la population
pour tous les français donc c'est
peut-être avoir apportera peut-être
point d'argent ça sera peut-être bon
vous aurez peut-être vous répète pas
certains santé un plaisir au pouvoir
mais vous pourrez faire des choses
extraordinaires parce que vous rendrez
vraiment un vrai service et si le hacker
il aurait pu - mais votre votre service
de renseignement sous-équipés qui fait
que des conneries depuis des années ici
est vraiment l'intérêt général des
français où il sert pas le pouvoir
politique et des business qui se font
encore globalement globalement
globalement et du renseignement servent
l'intérêt de l'état mais j'imagine
attendez quand j l'intérêt de l'état
l'intérêt national j'ai pas dit les
politiques jeudi globalement les
services de renseignement alors ce qu'il
ya c'est que de temps en temps
on l'a dit et c'est vrai il ya des
dérives c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
qui se mettent à servir à utiliser les
services de renseignement dans un cas
qui n'est plus celui que du wat est
celui des services de renseignement ça
dure jamais très longtemps vous pensez
un certain requins
je pense à certains requins mais je
pense à beaucoup et je pense à d'autres
gens je pense que j'ai tout à l'heure
quand le patron de la cia de l'époque a
dit eh ben oui on s'est trompé on
n'aurait pas dû faire ça il y en a
d'autres
questions non non non ils ont je veux
dire que si vous voulez il ya des dents
dans le passé il ya certains moments ou
non je pense que globalement les gens
les gens disent ont ils ont vraiment le
sens de l'état
donc le hacker on lui dit tu vas études
à céret et et y fera les trucs
formidables
ce qui va être payés correctement
ça à l'administration ne faut pas
continuer de payer très bien combien ça
touche 1 juillet en fin de carrière à la
dgse et je veux pas vous dire mais ça
touchait pas grand chose
ce que je peux vous dire que ça s'est
vraiment que j'étais avant d'être la
dgse j'étais patron j'étais président de
marks and spencer france en 2000 quand
j'ai accepté de passer la dgse j'ai
diminué mon salaire par huit
pas mal c'est ma femme qui vous
expliquerai que c'est pas drôle du tout
mais je les fais parce que j'étais je
trouvais que la fonction soul et le
poste et le post la fonction était
suffisamment passionnante pour justifier
de faire un effort financier vous dire
que j'ai pas un homme d'argent ça c'est
vrai il ya toujours et la soul diraient
certains enfin ça c'est ya toujours une
bonne femme extraordinaire derrière un
bonhomme est extraordinaire c'est ça
ouais bah oui à la je pense que oui il a
dans ce cas précis oui non non non non
non mais je dis pas ça pour ma femme
mais je pense que j'en connais d'autres
non mais j'en connais d'autres qui ont
fait la même chose que moi pas beaucoup
les gens qui passent du privé au public
et n'a pas beaucoup mais mais quand on
le fait c'est vrai que confirmant être
supporter parce que parce que votre
épouse est là pendant votre épouse votre
amis ou la famille ou votre copain peu
importe on se retrouve avec évidemment
un niveau de vie qui pour un vieux coup
mais d'un autre côté il ya des
satisfactions aussi ça aussi ça compte
on fait pas moi j'aime bien le système
américain insiste de ce côté là oui
c'est un américain il est simple quand
vous êtes dans l'administration
américaine vous êtes mal payés
mais avec le spoil system chaque fois
qu'il ya un changement de président vous
êtes viré vous partez dans le privé là
vous vous refait une santé et après vous
revenez vous êtes sorti avec quelques
dossiers en poche pour protéger vos
fesses vous êtes sorti de là déjà soupe
à ne rien du tout on ne peut pas fonder
riez pas par contre j'ai des choses dans
ma mémoire ça va
il nous reste
huit minutes avant d'arriver ou deux
heures on gratte un peu où je vous
voulez y avoir de fable moi c'est voulu
bref dépend de vous virer la danse allez
c'est parti à leurs hôtes question
d'internet peut-on être issus de
l'immigration pour travailler la dgs lui
bien sûr c'est nécessaire non ça peut
être nécessaire dans certains cas
c'est sûr que pour lui à partir du
moment où vous travaillez dans des
conditions dit dans un secteur une zone
difficile un secteur difficile ou au
tour dans un groupe difficile
bien sûr si vous travaillez avec je
prends un exemple si vous travaillez que
des africains un sens dans l'afrique
centrale et que vous êtes tout blanc ben
vous pouvez difficilement dire je suis
un futon frère c'est clair bon mais ça
ne veut pas dire vous pouvez pas le
faire hein
mais il ya des fois si on prend par
exemple les folies jihadistes bon c'est
un secret pour personne que les
meilleurs enfin les gens les plus utiles
sont souvent les gens qui sont qui
qu'aucune solution d'origine d'origine
maghrébine
votre question d'internet que je vais
formuler excuse moi je vais la
reformuler parce que sinon on va prévoir
réponse
je vais la pause est comme ça et puis si
j'ai besoin d'informer conviction où
c'est intéressant pour une entreprise
d'avoir une entreprise privée d'avoir un
pion de la dgse au sein de ses services
est-ce que c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir quelqu'un qui fait l'armée pour
détecter les risques non
conventionnelles ou est ce que les
entreprises françaises avec l'amsa est
ce que c'est parce qu'il ya toujours
près des gens des services dans les
salles de trading ce qui a toujours
devant non non non c'est pas non pour
une raison temps alors là je vais vous
dire sur les ceintures ring présent très
simple c'est que les gens des services
se sont pas des spécialistes des
problèmes financiers et les problèmes
économiques ce sont des gens qui ont des
formations dans beaucoup de domaines il
on recrute des gens de d'énormément de
domenech de grande qualité dans leur
domaine mais des gens des spécialistes
de l'économie cas n'a pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est ce que lui
faisait tout à l'heure c'est que
l'intelligence économique on a retrouvé
presque obligé de faire une activité à
part dans l'état pour faire de
l'intelligence économique et pour les
finances on a créé et racf un
trac fin qui est qui sont des
spécialistes alors là des banques mais
c'est unis vendée spécialisé manquait lé
rôle et que les mouvements financiers
c'est les champions du monde mais leur
demande et pas autre chose ils savent
pas faire on fait comment pour avoir
quelqu'un de plus + wallon c'est très
difficile en définitive parce que les
non mais c'est pas facile d'avoir des
polyvalents parce que vous avez il ya un
domaine de spécial on se spécialise les
gens et le polyvalent c'est celui qui
est capable de gérer d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble y en a très peu ce droit si
on peut dire oui si vous voulez le
polyvalent sais mais je fais rêver pour
préciser s'il voulait le
savez dans les services mais comme mais
c'est un peu comme les entreprises c'est
pareil hein dans les entreprises on a
des gens qui sont dans les entreprises
classiques 1 on a des gens qui sont
spécialisé dans un domaine une
entreprise c'est une série de six lots 1
il yal ingénieur industriel il ya le
spécialiste des relations humaines
spécialistes de la finance spécialiste
de la stratégie
du commercial ce sont tous des
spécialistes en définitive celui ou
celle ou ceux ci voulaient qu'ils sont
polyvalents ne sont pas des experts dans
chaque domaine mais sont capables de
coordonner les actions tout le monde
sait qui c'est les dirigeants
d'entreprise à ses directeurs généraux
ces gens comme ça bon dans les services
gax exactement la même chose vous avez
des spécialistes spécialiste de pays
vous avez les spécialistes par zone
géographique si vous voulez ou par
métier ou par activité dans leur domaine
ils sont très forts le reste ils savent
pas donc il ya très peu de gens qui sont
capables de faire la synthèse et c'est
ça le truc qu'est ce qu'on pensait dans
d'engager des autistes
vous à des calculs elle peut avoir la
mémoire d asperger ça c'est le
stéréotype du dur elle mène d'ailleurs
qu'ils n'étaient pas autiste
on en parle un peu maintenant dans les
entreprises d'engager des houthistes non
on ne parle pas une entreprise mais
c'est vrai qu'en france dans mais bien
sûr mais même à même ne parle pas
beaucoup de ça mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on découvre que certains
certaines personnes ont des
caractéristiques intellectuelle
particulière qui dans certains cas
peuvent être utilisés ça oui mais si
vous voulez y a pas que ça il ya une
époque les rues si on parlait des russes
tout à l'heure les russes ont beaucoup
travaillé sur les problèmes de les
problèmes de 2 de télé de télépathie
mais par exemple ils travailler
là-dessus
expérience de pensée pour elle
maintenant mais ils ont déjà travaillé
là dessus pour voir si on pouvait pas
justement donner des ordres par
télépathie et faire agir les gens par
télépathie ya eu d'énormes travaux qui
ont été faits chez les russes là dessus
et juste quelque chose qu'on a ressenti
ben on l'a on a su après quand on est
quand il ya eu l'ouverture de la russie
après la chute du pain avec helsinn à
son l'aller les tout le monde a été
regardé il y avait des dix ans ils sont
certains domaines il avait fait des il
avait fait des recherches très
intéressante bon donc il ya des domaines
le loto on sait où on sait maintenant
l'autisme mais on sait que les
difficultés les problèmes des autistes
on sait aussi qu'ils ont des cayes des
caractéristiques de mémoire de
mémorisation
de logique je dirais d'une certaine
logique qui dans certains cas peuvent
être très utiles mais de là à les
utiliser on n'est pas encore là c'est
encore très loin mais peut-être qu'un
jour ça arrivera un cuvier beau c'est le
problème des spécialisations un
lob vous savez les regarder l'homme
d'action l'homme d'action moi je vois à
une époque de ma carrière me faisait des
tests on nous faisait sauter en
parachute on testait en nous on nous
mesurer les battements cardiaques
avant pendant et à la rive avant le saut
ou s'il voulait toute l'opération
c'était fantastique parce qu'on vous ait
des gens qui étaient super entraînés qui
étaient des gens solides un général
enfin c'est pas c'était pas des pages
aurait pas des gens faibles ainsi que
les gens faibles bah c'est des gens qui
ceux qui s'inquiètent qui ce si vous
voulez qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas qu'ils
sont
ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont au top sont
pas intelligents au travail c'est des
gens qui physiquement parlant et
physiologiquement parlant ne sont pas
capables de prendre sur eux mêmes pour
faire quelque chose ce contrôle est
ciblée
et bien quand vous voyez bien ce qui
était étonnant là dedans si vous aviez
des gens que ça le
le cardiologue cardiomètre le budget le
hall terre ouais la dengue il ne
bougeait pas à dire que les types il
était en train de boire leur café il
monte dans un avion il sauté en
parachute de jour de nuit et autres il
arrivait au soleil ça n'avait pas bougé
il y en ad'autres ça monte à 180 200 ça
redescende est bon
et ça veut pas dire qu'ils étaient
mauvais est ce à dire qu'ils étaient
différents
ben selon ce que vous avez à faire il
faut choisir ceux qui sont les mieux
adaptées pour le faire
une question internet le yémen et le
pétrole syrien du plateau du golan
est-ce que c'est déjà vendu
alors le plateau du golan c'est pas une
question de pétrole c'est lui qui sur
mayotte ces questions de flotte si les
israéliens ont pris le contrôle du
plateau du golan c'est parce que les
eaux du glct du golan se déverse dans le
lac de tibériade et ça permet
d'approvisionner le jour d'un horizon un
énorme problème qu'ils avaient et
israéliens avaient d'énormes problèmes
d'eau il craignait qu'on leur coupe
l'eau et donc ils avaient besoin de
l'eau du lot du gol du golan c'est pour
ça la prise du golan ça a été ça au
désespoir des vielles syrien qui eux à
l'époque évidemment considéré que
c'était une réserve d'eau pour eux mais
qui n'exploitait pas puisque l'eau
descendait sur le lac du tiberium le
problème devient différent c'est pour ça
que peut-être y aura des négociations là
dessus dans le futur le problème devient
différent depuis que les eaux depuis que
les israéliens ont commencé à construire
des usines de dessalement d'eau de mer
dans le sud dans le negev en particulier
un dub aux usines de dessalement d'eau
de mer et qui font que ils vont pouvoir
approvisionner une bonne partie du pays
avec de l'eau qui vient une autre de
l'eau dessalée et donc ils ne seront
plus aussi dépendants qu'ils étaient du
journal et ce qui posait un élan
problèmes sont plus au journal st pose
le problème de l'eau de la jordanie de
la cisjordanie de tout le monde s'ils
voulaient céder 7,5 pour la main là cela
on peut faire une guerre avec ça pour de
l'eau les gens sont prêts à s'entretuer
un autre question d'internet donc entre
parenthèses beaucoup de questions sur
l'algérie
le lien entre la dgse et l'algérie pour
interrogation
l'algérie là y'a pas n'y a pas de
mauvaises dit de bonnes relations avec
l'algérie l'algérie on a la chance
aujourd'hui le pré le directeur de la
dgse et l'ancien ambassadeur de france
en algérie donc c'est quand même il a
des relations tout à fait exceptionnel à
titre personnel bon il est vrai qu'à une
époque mais il ya longtemps hein
à une époque les algériens avaient de
bonnes relations avec la dst
il avait de très
près du territoire 1 oui c'est ça oui ce
que moi la dir la direction de la
sécurité du territoire il avait
d'excellentes relations avec la dst il
travaillait très étroitement les
délaissés alors qu'ils avaient de très
mauvaises relations avec la dgse
pourquoi c'est parce que la dst c'était
des civils la dgse c'était des
militaires et pour les algériens
s'étaient les militaires qui s'étaient
battus contre eux pendant la guerre
d'algérie donc c'est des histoires
culturel si vous voulez on fait comment
pas le temps c'est ça être avant de
passer tout ça c'est fort heureusement
ça passe enfin on fait comment pour le
problème du terrorisme
en france les attentats par exemple
aujourd'hui en allemagne les je crois
qu'il ya bien une fois de chantiers
encore enfoncé dans une
famille stupa oui j'ai vu
ses effets comme en produisent ce
problème et non pas pour 30 ans ce qu'il
y'a combien si rouler je pense je pense
qu'on part pour longtemps parce que nous
avons en nous n'avons pas traité le
problème pendant longtemps pas voulu
voir leur n'a pas vu le voit puis
surtout l'exemple et si on aurait dû
commencer quand khaled kelkal si vous
souvenez il ya quand même maintenant ça
fait vingt ans plus de 20 ans
1/2 libéraux quand khaled kelkal avec
cfg bombinette ces petites bombes
avaient été à velcan ça a démarré c'est
à ce moment là que les politiques
auraient dû commencer à réagir en disant
pourquoi on en est arrivé là pourquoi un
type comme quelques années devenu un
terroriste
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi il
est appuyé par des réseaux parce qu'ils
avaient des réseaux aussi un et si on
avait commencé à faire l'analyse comme
aujourd'hui on l'a fait on serait rendu
compte qu'il fallait véritablement
prendre le problème à bras le corps il
ya quantité de choses à régler
on peut pas régler en un an s'ils
voulaient l'environnement des banlieues
les cités de non droit le
chômage il faut voir les imams dans les
mosquées dont la fin tout y passe il ya
de tout ce qu'ils voulaient qui font que
il ya quantité d'éléments qui crée la
possibilité de faire basculer quelqu'un
dans la radicalisation et de la
radicalisation dans le terrorisme hier
quantité d'éléments donc position veux
que ça s'arrête il faut répondre à
chacun des éléments ce n'est pas une
question de répression moi quand
j'entends les gens dire on va mettre les
gens en prison à les expulser c'est bien
gentil mais ça ne règle pas le problème
le problème il faut le prendre à la
basse et le problème à la base ça va
nous prendre 20 ans pour la régler
on a dit que mehr a été un vfb avec
certains services baissent il a été dit
oui qui l'a été ce contrôle d'un agent
de la dg si oui alors c'est quoi abbas
il arrive que il arrive qu'on se fasse
dépasser par par là
la source qu'on traite un officier
traitant peut se faire avoir par sa
source
on arrive pratiquement à la fin de notre
interview j'espère que vous revenez vous
viendrez pour nous revoir pour josiane
seule la deuxième semaine
notre dernière question c'est pas une
question s'est laissé un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
quelque chose qui va être impérissable
sur les réseaux on est à destination des
jeunes
on vous laisse et puis je vous
demanderai de faire un conseil pour les
jeunes générations qui souhaitent
s'intéresser aux services de
renseignement pour leur pays plutôt dg
dgse plutôt direction du renseignement
militaire plutôt quoi c'est à vous la
parole
d'abord moi je pense qu'on vit nu n'est
pas d'abord je pense qu'on vit une
époque extraordinaire une époque
formidable
parce que comme l'a dit comme le disait
michel serres et c'est là on est en vie
la troisième révolution après
l'invention du langage et l'invention de
l'écriture
il ya eu aussi à une imprimerie il ya eu
langage et la l'écriture il ya eu les
imprimeries et maintenant avec
l'internet avec le web on est rentré
dans un autre mur entre dans une autre
dimension
donc qui ouvre des opportunités énormes
à ceux qui savent les saisir donc je
crois que le mois là pour le donc pour
la jeune génération
je dis surtout croyez croyez croyez en
vous croyez en l'avenir ne voyez pas
l'avenir comme une fatalité et voyez là
comme une formidable espérance
ça c'est pour moi c'est très important
parce que à partir du moment où on a une
vision positive de l'avenir qu'on arrête
de gémir sur son sort mais qu'au
contraire on se dit il ya plein
d'opportunités à saisir on en trouve et
on fait des choses et j'en la jeune
génération je voudrais d'ailleurs la
montée en puissance des start up de ce
côté là est très intéressante en france
on dit et que la france n'était pas
capable de faire une innovation va
excusez moi à las vegas au salon de las
vegas les français ce sont les ce sont
des vénètes c'est bien la preuve qu'on
peut y arriver mais il n'ya pas que les
start-ups et un état d'esprit général si
vous voulez parce que comme tout est en
train de changer comme tous les
paramètres sont en train de bouleverser
d'être il faut ce qu'ils comprennent et
qu'ils regardent et qui observe qui
essaie de comprendre
vont voir des opportunités qui s'ouvrent
et s'ils ont justement cette capacité
d'oser cette capacité de se dire ben j'y
vais ils vont se donner les résultats 9
mois moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une époque formidable
je regrette je regrette mon âge parce
que moi j'adorerais avoir beaucoup moins
pour pouvoir me lancer dans ce qui se
passe ça c'est le première partie si
vous de votre question ensuite pour les
services
je crois que je me réjouis d'ailleurs de
voir que
les français la jeune génération je
pense aussi grâce à beaucoup de choses
grâce à ce qui se passe grâce grâce au
film si aux informations qui sortent aux
articles aux émissions qui sortent se
rendre compte qu'en définitive un
service les services du renseignement
d'abord c'est une nécessité pour un état
pour pouvoir s'en sortir dans une
compétition qui est terrible au niveau
mondial et où personne ne se fait de
cadeau nous n'avons pas d'amis il faut
bien se mettre ça dans la tête on n'a
pas d'amis dans le monde on a des
partenaires on a des alliés temporaire
on n'a pas d'amis chacun si chacun pour
soi et c'est ça et dieu pour tous mais
comment comme on dit en français à
partir de ce moment là les services de
renseignement sont ceux qui peuvent
décoder
s'ils font bien leur boulot c'est ce
qu'ils peuvent décoder justement ces
éléments dont on a besoin pour pouvoir
mener une politique pour pouvoir
développer un pays pour pouvoir
envisager un futur un futur le meilleur
possible donc on a besoin d'eux donc
s'intéresser aux services de
renseignements que ce soit en défensif
la dgsi ou en offensif avec la dgse ça
va vous permettre ça permet ça va ça
peut permettre à des jeunes d'abord de
faire des métiers passionnants parce que
vous rendez un vrai service et vous fait
des choses intéressantes parce que vous
devez vous servir de votre et de votre
intelligence vous devez vous servir des
moyens qui sont mis à votre disposition
même s'ils sont souvent insuffisants on
l'a dit mais on peut faire plein de
choses et c'est très gratifiant parce
que quelque chose que vous avez faits
qui vous a permis et goût dont vous
voyez un résultat si vous voulez c'est
quand même fantastique quand vous dites
bah tiens on a trouvé ça ça nous a
permis de faire de permettre d'éviter un
attentat dans certains cas pour d'autres
ça va être de gagner un contrat
d'entreprise alors que bon on avait
contre nous tous le monde etc s'avère
derrière ça veut dire que c'est un
mieux-être pour l'ensemble de la
population sous une forme ou sous une
autre moi je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui compte si vous voulez je pense
que la jeune génération
elle ne doit pas uniquement penser si
vous voulez à l'argent parce que moi je
suis je suis dans une génération qui a
vécu 50 en même temps depuis depuis les
années 90 fait 25 ans que l'on nous a
tués avec les soirs de la création de
valeur pour l'actionnaire cette le
concept de création de valeur pour
l'actionnaire on ne dira jamais assez
comme ça fait de mal à nos sociétés
parce que en disant on ne prend que pour
les riches et donc on exploite tous les
autres c'est une catastrophe au niveau
des équilibres de la société or c'est en
train de changer tout le monde se rend
compte mais oui quand vous avez un
rapport en france qui vient de sortir on
dit il faut changer le système il faut
il faut arrêter que ce soit uniquement
l'actionnaire qui encaisse bon sur don
est pas arrivé au bout de leur combat du
wishful thinking ce nom quand luis foule
thinking nombreux méchants maison mais
parce que non non parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de pays de penseurs qui
sont en train de dire la même chose des
vagues c'est une lame qui monte est-ce
qu'on va réussir à dépasser la masse
inertielle pour pouvoir basculer le
système il faut tout faire pour ça
croiser les doigts il faut non sommet
pour croiser oui il faut croiser les
deux
fera 2 2 de questions internet comment
s'informer comment décrypter l'actualité
géopolitique là il faut lire et ne pas
croire ce qu'on lit je m'explique voilà
premièrement il faut lire mais il faut
pas lire ou écouter qu'un journal il
faut lire d'autres journaux compris les
journaux russes bien sûr
moi je vais vous dire moi j'ai par
exemple actuellement moi j'ai mangé
charge l'information partout il ya un
truc qui commet ben je me suis abonné à
des banques de données à des à des
lettres confidentielles et autres pour
savoir ce qui se passe bon il ya par
exemple il ya bon vous avez il ya une
royale banque de données
qui donnent des informations aux tempes
via l'iran tu es souvent la référence
c'est l'iran mais l'iran hills a plein
de trucs qui vont vous dire pas
forcément voir il faut faire la part des
choses mais vous allez apprendre plein
de choses sur ce qui se passe au liban
en israël ou ailleurs parce qu'ils en
savent des choses si vous croisez ça
avec ce que vous disent les israéliens
ou ce que vous disent les américains ben
vous commencez à avoir une petite idée
de la vérité est ce que je reproche dans
la sphère skripal qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure c'est qu'on a écouté que theresa
may et les américains alors qu'on aurait
peut-être dû aussi écouter les autres et
refaire un pas dans l'histoire ancienne
non pas avec la sphère du polonium et
duga de living and co mais revoir toutes
les histoires qui a pu avoir depuis des
années en russie
et en europe le ter est ailleurs est ce
que vous vous parlez de la russie et
puis comme on a contre le la dans ce
canton voile autant s'amuser à amasser
des troupes à la frontière russe dont on
voit l'europe autoriser les mouvements
de troupes au sein de nos territoires
quand on voit la suède réimprimer un
petit fascicule préparait sa population
à une guerre contre la russie quand on
voit sur arte une série qui présente les
russes comme des bêtes à cornes oui nous
les français on fait quoi on fait comme
le coq le matin à 5 heures du matin on
va je pense je pense que je pense que
merde et on se met à chanter très fort
pour réveiller tout le monde non je
pense que les fois les français et les
allemands d'ailleurs les deux les
français les allemands doivent gare
raison gardée par rapport aux autres de
ne pas laisser justement trop influencée
par des messages de l'extérieur où les
manipulations de l'extérieur
personne n'a intérêt à signer cible une
manipulation extérieure c'est qu'il
extérieur va écouter les anglo saxons
jeu c'est clair
ces anglo saxons le lebanese
actuellement les mouvements les
mouvements il est évident que
faire une guerre aujourd'hui à la russie
bon faut être sérieux le budget
américain il fait 6 110 milliards de
dollars budget militaire américain le
budget russe fait 65 milliards de
dollars dix fois moins
vous pensez vraiment que c'est un enjeu
majeur pour les états unis dont je me
jure c'est faire tomber largeur et quand
vous regardez les chinois ils mettent
210 milliards de dollars en
investissements militaires
l'arabie saoudite 105 milliards de
dollars dirk l'arabie saoudite fait
pratiquement deux fois l'investissement
des russes est-ce qu'on va massé des
troupes devant l'arabie saoudite on voit
bien que c'est de la manipulation tout
ça on a voulu connais ça s'il était la
pierre connaissez vous le dirais on a
voulu les occidentaux ont voulu se créer
un ennemi qu'est la russie parce que
c'est un ennemi facile
est ce que les démocrates américains en
particulier conquis pouce parce que
celui démocrate essentiellement qui
pousse à la lutte contre la russie nous
conservateur surtout b et les
néoconservateurs oui mais sous scellés
drôle ensemble c'est parce qu'en
définitive la chine ça les ennuie
beaucoup d'aller contre d'abord parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'affaires qui se font
entre la chine etats unis donc c'est
quand même pour le business c'est pas
très bon alors qu'il ya pas beaucoup d
affaires qui sont avec la russie donc la
russie est un état n'est un ennemi
facile si je peux dire alors que la
chine est un ennemi beaucoup plus
compliqué d'autant plus que les chinois
se laisse pas faire vous avez vu ce qui
se passe trump hiddink change je vais
taxer et vers les autres ils disent on
taxe aussi un donc c'est c'la le donc on
s'est choisi un ennemi facile mais je
crois qu'il faut pas il faut pas se
leurrer si vous voulez il ya beaucoup d'
une paille à une énorme part de
manipulation là dedans d'un côté et de
l'autre il ya des réactions qui sont
aussi je dis pas qu'ils sont doubles en
a les russes à moi je vous dis pas
qu'ils sont blancs non plus hein parce
que ils en font aussi un il faut pas se
leurrer on a bien vu mais je dirais que
c'est une guerre de communication de
médiatisation dans lesquelles les dés ne
sont pas tout à fait valais les parts ne
sont pas tout à fait équilibrée voilà
on parle de coups l'aps au logis en ce
moment sur les réseaux ça vous parle la
colonne son logis
anticipez-vous un effondrement question
d'internet
non mais là je crois que c'est vous
savez moi je suis plus vieux beaucoup
des gens qui de cuisson qui dialoguent
là moi je me souviens diaby a pas mal
d'années 1 on nous avait annoncé pour le
blanc 2000 la fin du monde le club de
rome nous allons ce la fin du monde pour
le l'an 2000 sol est la pénurie totale
il y aurait plus rien il y aurait plus
de pétrole y aurait plus de 11 serait un
cas ça serait la fin qu'on fait
référence au rapport midouze ouais bon à
chaque fois il ya toujours des gens qui
ont il ya toujours des gens qui vous qui
vous annoncent les pires catastrophes
ceci dit je ne leur jette pas totalement
la pierre parce que quand il nous dit ça
ça nous oblige à réfléchir va nous
obliger à réfléchir et à dire et si
jamais ça arrivait alors on dit non ça
ne peut pas arriver mais enfin quand
même s'il y avait ça ou ça ou ça
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui se
passerait prenons des mesures de
protection de prévention autres donc
c'est bien qu'ils aient des gens qui ça
mais il faut pas pour autant l'aigle et
prendre pour argent comptant parce que
je pense que ils vont beaucoup trop loin
voilà
est-ce que vous voyez un sujet pour
aborder comme ça on trouve qu'on n'a pas
traité on m'a fait beaucoup il a parlé
de beaucoup de choses
alain julié merci merci à vous et
surtout coupée
[Musique]
e